Welcome back to the second drink of the merger. Director Ken Whittingham joins us for this episode and one of my favorite things he shares with us is how strategic they were with where all of the new employees would sit in the Dunder Mifflin bullpen. You know, and that really helped shape some of these new storylines with the Stanford branch joining the Scranton branch. I love that as well. I thought that was one of like,
欢迎回到《办公室》合并特辑的第二部分。导演肯·惠廷汉姆（Ken Whittingham）参加了本期节目，他分享的内容中我最喜欢的一点是，他们对于邓德·米夫林（Dunder Mifflin）办公区新员工座位的安排有多么讲究。你知道，这确实有助于塑造斯坦福分部并入斯克兰顿分部后的一些新剧情。我也很喜欢这一点。我觉得那是……
when I think about our whole series rewatch and different interviews we did with people, I felt like that was one of like a key nugget. Yeah. You know, we also talk about who can see each other from their desks and which characters are no longer in each other's line of sight. Yeah.
当我们回顾整个系列以及我们对不同人员进行的采访时，我觉得那是一个关键点。是的。你知道，我们还谈到了谁能从座位上看到谁，以及哪些角色不再处于彼此的视线范围内。是的。
Loved that. Loved that. Jenna, you shared how you realized that Pam will no longer look up and see Jim at his desk anymore. Yeah, his back is to her. That's right. And there was a deleted scene between Jim and Pam
太棒了。太棒了。珍娜，你分享了你是如何意识到帕姆再也无法抬头看到吉姆坐在他的办公桌前了。是的，他背对着她。没错。而且吉姆和帕姆之间有一个被删减的片段，
where they're all flirty flirt, and it's annoying the crap out of Ryan. Because Pam has basically walked up to chat to Jim because his back is to her. So she can't like make eye contact with him. We talked a little bit about this moment, but we didn't play it, and I think we should hear it. This is weird with you facing the other way.
他们在那儿打情骂俏，把瑞安烦得要死。因为帕姆基本上是走过来找吉姆聊天，因为他背对着她。所以她没法和他进行眼神交流。我们稍微谈到了这个时刻，但我们没有播放它，我觉得我们应该听听。你面向另一边感觉真奇怪。
Yeah, I never even knew that part of the office existed. Hey, who's that guy? That's Stanley Hudson. Huh. He's one of our salesmen. Seems like a nice enough guy. Oh, very. What about, uh...
是啊，我甚至都不知道办公室还有那一部分。嘿，那个人是谁？那是斯坦利·哈德森。嗯。他是我们的销售员之一。看起来是个不错的人。哦，非常不错。那，呃……
Hmm. That is Janet Fenstermaker. Really? You should say hi. Use her full name. Thank you for all of this. This is so helpful. You know what? One last question.
嗯。那是珍妮特·芬斯特梅克。真的吗？你应该去打个招呼。用她的全名。谢谢你所做的一切。这太有帮助了。你知道吗？最后一个问题。
Who is that fine older gentleman in the corner? That is Creed Bratton. He has four toes and he fought in the Civil War. For the North? For both sides. Whoever paid more. Obviously. Yeah. Hey, sorry. Seriously, can you guys, I'm trying to get some work done. Sorry, man.
角落里那位风度翩翩的老绅士是谁？那是克里德·布拉顿。他有四个脚趾，还参加过内战。为北方？为双方。谁给的钱多就为谁。显然。是啊。嘿，抱歉。说真的，你们能安静点吗？我正试着完成一些工作。抱歉，伙计。
I love Ryan so much. So much. And you know who she's talking about when she says the Janet? Is that Phyllis? Meredith. Oh, okay. Well, also in this episode, we talk about Andy's nifty, gifty bags, and we talked about the fakey bag, that that was a prop bag that we would use
我太喜欢瑞安了。太喜欢了。你知道她说“那个珍妮特”时指的是谁吗？是菲利斯吗？是梅雷迪斯。哦，好吧。另外，在这一集中，我们谈到了安迪的“精美礼品袋”，我们谈到了那种“假袋子”，那是我们拍摄时会用到的道具袋，
when we were filming because they were silent. And we sort of mentioned we weren't sure what those bags were, but Angela, you said someone wrote in and told us. Yes, thank you Emma B for writing in to tell us that those type of bags are actually made of vinyl. Oh. Yeah. So they hardly make any noise
因为它们是静音的。我们稍微提了一下，不确定那些袋子是什么，但安吉拉，你说有人写信告诉了我们。是的，感谢艾玛·B（Emma B）写信告诉我们那种袋子其实是乙烯基做的。哦。是啊。所以它们几乎不会发出任何声音，
and that helps the sound department. And Jenna, you'll love this. She called it a quote, Foley Fun Fact. Oh, I love that. Foley Fun Fact. After Jack Foley. Right. Yes, you know I love moviemaking trivia
这有助于音效部门的工作。珍娜，你会喜欢这个的。她称之为“拟音趣闻”。哦，我喜欢这个。拟音趣闻。以杰克·福利（Jack Foley）命名。对吧？是的，你知道我喜欢电影制作的冷知识。
and Jack Foley is the person who developed all of the sound effect techniques that were used in the early days of filmmaking. You've seen it sometime in movies where they're watching it live and they're making these noises using different things. Well, if you do the Universal Studios tour, at least here in California, they have a whole like, show. It's like the Foley Artist Show. Have you done it? No. It's like the Foley artist show. Have you done it? It's so fun. We did it
杰克·福利是开发了电影制作早期所使用的所有音效技术的人。你有时在电影里看到他们现场观看并利用各种东西制造噪音。嗯，如果你参加环球影城的游览，至少在加州这里，他们有一个完整的表演。就像“拟音师表演”。你参加过吗？没有。就像“拟音师表演”。你参加过吗？太有趣了。我们和孩子们一起参加过，
with our kids and they'll pull people up on stage and you'll each get like a different sound effect and you have to like watch the screen and make the sound effect to go with it. That's so fun. Yeah like you'll put shoes on your hands and make clumpy sounds. For a horse. Yeah it was so cool. Well thank you Emma for writing and to share your fully fun fact with us. Lastly, before we get to our breakdown, there is one more deleted scene that we wanted to play because many of you have noted that Jim and Angela rarely have scenes together where they actually speak to one another throughout the entire series. I'm not talking about like if we're in a conference room. I'm talking about Jim and Angela having a back and forth.
他们会把人拉上台，每个人都会得到一个不同的音效，你必须看着屏幕并配合它发出音效。太有趣了。是啊，就像你把鞋子套在手上发出沉重的脚步声。为了模拟马。是啊，太酷了。好吧，谢谢艾玛写信与我们分享你的拟音趣闻。最后，在我们进入剧情拆解之前，还有一个我们想播放的被删减片段，因为你们中的许多人注意到，在整个系列中，吉姆和安吉拉很少有真正交谈的场景。我不是指我们在会议室里的那种情况。我说的是吉姆和安吉拉之间的对话。
Yes, this was very similar, the observation that Stanley and Creed almost never speak to each other. That's right. All right, well, you talked about this scene in our initial breakdown, but we didn't play it. And I really thought we needed to hear one of these few times that Jim and Angela
是的，这和斯坦利和克里德几乎从不交谈的观察非常相似。没错。好吧，你在我们最初的拆解中谈到了这个场景，但我们没有播放它。我真的觉得我们需要听听吉姆和安吉拉这为数不多的几次
speak directly to one another. Jim has just returned to the Scranton branch and is talking to Kevin over an accounting. Let's hear it. Hey, Kev. Hey, man. How are you doing? Good. Listen, my M&Ms are under the desk if you want any.
直接交谈的时刻。吉姆刚回到斯克兰顿分部，正在和凯文谈论会计部的事。让我们听听。嘿，凯夫。嘿，伙计。你怎么样？很好。听着，如果你想要的话，我的M&M豆在桌子下面。
OK. Hidden from them. Smart. Good. Hey, Angela. You need a haircut. Bye, Angela. Alright, Kev. See you later, Jack. See you later. It's his first day back. His hair's flipping out on the sides.
好的。藏起来不让他们看见。聪明。很好。嘿，安吉拉。你需要理发了。再见，安吉拉。好了，凯夫。回头见，杰克。回头见。这是他回来的第一天。他的头发在两边乱翘。
I like it. Oh, my lord. I mean, I think this might be why I like it. Oh my lord. I mean, I think this might be why he doesn't speak to Angela. I know. I know. Also, that last line, obviously, you know, I talked about this, I improvised it, but could it be more not in character? Oh my lord. That's true.
我喜欢。哦，天哪。我的意思是，我想这可能就是我喜欢它的原因。哦，天哪。我的意思是，我想这可能就是他为什么不和安吉拉说话的原因。我知道。我知道。还有，最后那句台词，显然，你知道，我谈过这个，我是即兴发挥的，但还有比这更不符合角色设定的吗？哦，天哪。那倒是真的。
Well, now you guys, here is the breakdown of the merger. I'm Jenna Fischer. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies. Hello, it's the merger.
好了，各位，这就是关于合并的拆解。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们将拆解一集《办公室》，并提供只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士。你好，这是合并。
Hi everyone. We're merging. Where are we merging to? We are merging two worlds today. Angela, the Stamford and the Scranton branches. Not all of the Stamford branch, but some will be merging with Scranton. I also feel like we're merging as friends because I'm looking at you. I think we have almost the same outfit on today. You know, I mean, seriously, like, they always say, like, pet owners start to look
大家好。我们要合并了。我们要合并到哪里？我们今天正在合并两个世界。安吉拉，斯坦福分部和斯克兰顿分部。不是整个斯坦福分部，但一部分将与斯克兰顿合并。我也觉得我们作为朋友也在合并，因为我看着你。我觉得我们今天穿的衣服几乎一模一样。你知道，我的意思是，说真的，就像他们常说的，宠物主人开始变得
like they're pets. Like, best friends start to look like each other and like husbands and wives and partners. Like, I feel like we're starting to look like each other and like husbands and wives and partners like I feel like we're starting to look like each other. We might be. Also, neither one of us has had a haircut or a hair color in a very long time. I did my own hair color, lady. I did too. Well, actually, Lee did mine with my hair colorist on FaceTime. I did mine. But no, I haven't had a haircut and I kind of given up on makeup. Just lipstick. Do you notice I only wear lipstick?
像他们的宠物。就像最好的朋友开始变得像对方，就像丈夫和妻子和伴侣一样。我觉得我们开始变得像对方了。我们可能确实是。而且，我们俩都很久没有理发或染发了。我自己染的头发，女士。我也一样。好吧，其实是李通过FaceTime指导我的发型师帮我弄的。我自己弄的。但没有，我没理过发，而且我有点放弃化妆了。只涂口红。你注意到我只涂口红了吗？
Yeah, you show up to these Zooms in lipstick. I was walking out to my That's What She Said to start the Zoom and I put on a little lipstick and the kids were like, why are you putting on lipstick? And I was like, because I'm, yeah, because. Yes, I will be on a Zoom. I'm going to be I don't know why. I will be on a Zoom. I'm gonna be on a Zoom. Alright.
是啊，你每次参加这些Zoom会议都涂着口红。我正走出去准备开始Zoom会议，我涂了一点口红，孩子们问我，你为什么要涂口红？我说，因为我，是啊，因为。是的，我要参加Zoom会议。我要去……我不知道为什么。我要参加Zoom会议。我要参加Zoom会议。好了。
Well, this is season three, episode eight, written by Brent Forrester and directed by Ken Whittingham. Do you want a summary? I do want a summary. Alright, good. The Stanford branch merges with the Scranton branch, which means Jim will be returning to his old stomping ground. Oh.
好吧，这是第三季第八集，由布伦特·福雷斯特（Brent Forrester）编剧，肯·惠廷汉姆（Ken Whittingham）执导。你想要剧情摘要吗？我确实想要摘要。好吧，很好。斯坦福分部与斯克兰顿分部合并，这意味着吉姆将回到他的老地盘。哦。
Oh. Woo hoo hoo. Woo hoo hoo. Pam is so excited. Michael does his best to welcome the Stanford transplants, but he goes a bit too far, causing one employee to quit. But Michael tries to save face by then firing him, leaving Dunder Mifflin with having to pay a sizable severance. Jan's not happy.
哦。呜呼呼。呜呼呼。帕姆太兴奋了。迈克尔尽其所能欢迎斯坦福的“移植”员工，但他做得有点过火，导致一名员工辞职。但迈克尔试图通过解雇他来挽回面子，导致邓德·米夫林不得不支付一笔可观的遣散费。简很不高兴。
Jan is not happy. Meanwhile, Pam senses something is going on with Jim and Karen, and Dwight clashes with Andy. Good summary, lady. Thanks. You know what I started realizing? What? You know how I have that Bible from the office, the office Bible? Yeah.
简很不高兴。与此同时，帕姆感觉到吉姆和凯伦之间有些不对劲，而德怀特和安迪发生了冲突。很好的摘要，女士。谢谢。你知道我开始意识到什么了吗？什么？你知道我有那本《办公室》圣经吗？是啊。
Yeah. Every show has a summary. Every episode has a summary in the office Bible. So I've been able to now refer to the office Bible summary. I tweak it a little. I put a little zhuzh on it. But yeah, I used to just sit down at a blank page and think, how do I summarize this episode? And a team
是啊。每一集在《办公室》圣经里都有一个摘要。所以我现在能够参考《办公室》圣经的摘要了。我稍微调整了一下。我加了一点润色。但是的，我以前只是坐在空白页面前想，我该如何总结这一集？而一个编剧团队
of writers have done it for me and it was just sitting on my desk. So if you've noticed my summaries are getting better, it's thanks to the Office Bible. Wow. How excited were you when you realized there were some reason there? You must have been so excited. Lady, yes, so excited. Fast fact number one, this episode was directed by Ken Whittingham. We've talked a little bit about Ken before. Ken directed nine episodes of The Office, including this one, and we reached out to
已经为我做好了，它就放在我的桌子上。所以如果你注意到我的摘要越来越好了，那要归功于《办公室》圣经。哇。当你意识到那里有摘要时，你有多兴奋？你一定非常兴奋。女士，是的，非常兴奋。第一个快讯，这一集是由肯·惠廷汉姆执导的。我们之前谈过一点肯。肯执导了九集《办公室》，包括这一集，我们联系了
him. Yes, and he sent in some audio clips. We're really excited to hear him talk about this episode. And Jenna, he is going to come on and be a full Zoom guest for Phyllis's wedding. I don't want to get ahead of ourselves, but we're very excited. Yes, and Phyllis's wedding is such a milestone episode, and so is this. We wanted to ask Ken, what was it like to merge these two worlds? And a lot of people wrote in wanting to know, how did they decide where everybody would sit in the office?
他。是的，他发来了一些音频片段。我们非常兴奋能听到他谈论这一集。而且珍娜，他会作为完整的Zoom嘉宾来参加菲利斯的婚礼。我不想操之过急，但我们非常兴奋。是的，菲利斯的婚礼是一个里程碑式的剧集，这一集也是。我们想问肯，合并这两个世界是什么感觉？很多人写信想知道，他们是如何决定每个人在办公室坐在哪里的？
Like if you notice, suddenly the desk pods go from two to three. Yeah, I remember being so happy that Ken was the one directing this because we already knew Ken really well, We were so comfortable with him. And this was big even for the cast, Jenna. There was a buzz because we hadn't been around these people and we barely got to see them at table reads and things like that. So there was a real sort of buzz on set. And I remember being happy that Ken was there because he's so calm and like he was going to guide us through the merger. Well, here is his audio clip explaining how he and Greg decided where all the new people would sit.
比如如果你注意到，突然间办公桌组合从两个变成了三个。是啊，我记得当时很高兴肯是这一集的导演，因为我们已经很了解肯了，我们和他在一起很自在。这对演员来说也是件大事，珍娜。当时有一种骚动，因为我们之前没和这些人在一起过，我们在剧本朗读会上几乎没怎么见过他们。所以片场有一种真正的骚动。我记得很高兴肯在那里，因为他非常冷静，他会引导我们完成合并。好吧，这是他的音频片段，解释了他和格雷格是如何决定新员工坐在哪里的。
Introducing the characters from the Stanford branch will be very important to establish these characters and how they interacted with the Scranton employees, their likes and their dislikes for each other. I remember Greg Daniels asking me to decide where the new characters were sitting and why. So he and I walked to set and I laid out where I thought everyone should be. Since Ryan had taken Jim's old desk,
介绍斯坦福分部的角色，对于确立这些角色以及他们如何与斯克兰顿员工互动、他们对彼此的喜好和厌恶非常重要。我记得格雷格·丹尼尔斯（Greg Daniels）让我决定新角色坐在哪里以及原因。所以他和我在片场走了一圈，我布置了我认为每个人应该坐的位置。由于瑞安占了吉姆原来的座位，
I decided that Jim would sit directly across from Dwight, which would be fun for Jim and irritating to Dwight. It would also put Jim in the middle of Karen and Pam, which will also make Jim uncomfortable and Pam to be able to check out interactions between him and Karen. I sent Andy in between Kevin and Angela to establish Andy's instant attraction to Angela and also they would be in Dwight's eye line to create Dwight's jealousy. Andy would later move on to Karen's desk.
我决定让吉姆直接坐在德怀特对面，这对吉姆来说会很有趣，对德怀特来说则很烦人。这也会把吉姆放在凯伦和帕姆中间，这会让吉姆感到不舒服，也能让帕姆观察他和凯伦之间的互动。我把安迪安排在凯文和安吉拉之间，以确立安迪对安吉拉的瞬间吸引力，而且他们会在德怀特的视线范围内，从而制造德怀特的嫉妒。安迪后来会搬到凯伦的桌子。
I placed Tony in the back near Toby at a very obscure desk because he would be quitting or getting fired in that episode. We also discussed how important it was to build Pam's awareness that Jim had moved on and was interested in Karen. I love how much thought went into where everyone sat. I love it so much. I love the idea of, depending on which character, who could see who, right?
我把托尼放在靠近托比的后面，在一个非常不起眼的桌子上，因为他会在那一集中辞职或被解雇。我们还讨论了建立帕姆的意识有多重要，即吉姆已经向前看并对凯伦感兴趣了。我喜欢在座位安排上投入的思考。我太喜欢了。我喜欢这种想法，取决于角色，谁能看到谁，对吧？
Yes. Yeah. And thinking about it from Pam's perspective, and I remember sitting at the desk, and there's even a moment in the episode when Pam realizes she's not gonna be able to see Jim's face anymore. Yeah.
是的。是啊。从帕姆的角度来考虑，我记得坐在桌子旁，剧集中甚至有一个时刻，帕姆意识到她再也看不到吉姆的脸了。是啊。
There's a whole deleted scene about that, lady, where you actually come up to him, and you're like, this is kind of weird. I just stare at your back now. It's really, it's a great deleted scene and, and you and Jim start doing a bit. And then Ryan's like, can you guys stop? I'm just trying to get some work done. It's really awkward.
有一个完整的被删减片段是关于那个的，女士，你实际上走到他面前，说，这有点奇怪。我现在只能盯着你的后背看。这是一个很棒的被删减片段，你和吉姆开始演戏。然后瑞安说，你们能停下吗？我正试着完成一些工作。真的很尴尬。
Oh my gosh. I want to go back and see that. Because also after I heard Ken's clip, I was thinking about how, wow, so now Pam can see Karen's face. So if Karen is making flirty googly eyes at Jim or something, she doesn't know if Jim is reciprocating or not because she can only see the back of his head. Yeah. So in terms of Pam trying to track this relationship going forward, she's only going to have that
天哪。我想回去看看那个。因为在听了肯的片段后，我也在想，哇，所以现在帕姆可以看到凯伦的脸了。所以如果凯伦在对吉姆抛媚眼或者什么的，她不知道吉姆是否在回应，因为她只能看到他的后脑勺。是啊。所以就帕姆试图追踪这段关系的发展而言，她只能看到
one thing she can see. I just love all the thought that goes into these choices. Yes. And some people I saw wrote in and asked, why would Andy sit in Oscar's desk and where is Oscar? But you have to remember, Oscar is on his paid vacation leave. So his desk was available. Yeah. Although I will say this, Angela,
那一点点。我喜欢这些选择背后的所有思考。是的。有些人写信问，为什么安迪会坐在奥斯卡的桌子上，奥斯卡在哪里？但你必须记住，奥斯卡正在休带薪假。所以他的桌子是空的。是啊。虽然我要说这个，安吉拉，
someone wrote in to note that the character of Hannah is technically an accountant. Oh! Yeah, so maybe... That's another layer why my character feels so threatened by her. Yeah, exactly. There can only be one bitch in accounting.
有人写信指出，汉娜这个角色在技术上是一名会计。哦！是啊，所以也许……这是我的角色感到被她威胁的另一个层面。是啊，没错。会计部只能有一个婊子。
All right, well, I loved that. Let's move on to fastback number two. This is the first episode featuring writer Brent Forrester. Yes. And Brent also sent in audio clips. We asked him a lot of questions and he sent in clips as well. So all throughout this episode, you guys, we're going to have clips from Ken, the director, and Brent, the writer, which is just so fun. Yeah.
好吧，我喜欢这个。让我们进入第二个快讯。这是第一集由编剧布伦特·福雷斯特（Brent Forrester）执笔。是的。布伦特也发来了音频片段。我们问了他很多问题，他也发来了片段。所以整集节目，伙计们，我们都会有来自导演肯和编剧布伦特的片段，这太有趣了。是啊。
I love getting to have those different perspectives. So, Angele, you asked Brent about what it was like for him to write his first episode. Yeah. This was his first episode, and it's such a huge one. I was like, Brent, that feels very intimidating. You're writing the merger of Scranton and Stanford. What was that like? Yeah. And this is what he had to say. Hi, I'm Brent Forrester, the author of The Merger. I was not part of the original
我喜欢拥有那些不同的视角。所以，安吉拉，你问布伦特他写第一集是什么感觉。是啊。这是他的第一集，而且是非常重要的一集。我说，布伦特，这感觉非常令人生畏。你在写斯克兰顿和斯坦福的合并。那是什么感觉？是啊。这是他要说的。嗨，我是布伦特·福雷斯特，《合并》的作者。我不是《办公室》最初的
writing staff of The Office. Greg Daniels, the show creator, was a writer with me on The Simpsons and he had me as a writer on King of the Hill. He brought me in in season three. And what I remember most about writing this draft was how I totally failed in the first draft to capture the tone of the office. I was trying so hard to be funny. I wrote witticisms for every character in the office every time they opened their mouth,
编剧团队成员。格雷格·丹尼尔斯，该剧的创作者，曾和我一起在《辛普森一家》担任编剧，他让我担任了《山丘之王》的编剧。他在第三季把我带了进来。关于写这一稿，我记忆最深的是我在第一稿中是如何完全没能捕捉到《办公室》的基调的。我太努力想变得有趣了。我为办公室里的每个角色写了俏皮话，每次他们开口，
and Greg was so horrified. He made Mike Schur, Jen Salata, and Paul Lieberstein, the three senior writers on the show, sit me down and explain to me the tone of the office, which is the tone of naturalism, where we don't require characters to be saying funny things all the time,
格雷格感到非常震惊。他让迈克·舒尔（Mike Schur）、詹·萨拉塔（Jen Salata）和保罗·利伯斯坦（Paul Lieberstein），这三位剧组资深编剧，让我坐下来，向我解释《办公室》的基调，即自然主义的基调，我们不需要角色一直说有趣的话，
where we let things be dramatic for long stretches, and where we get comedy from performance above all. Well, I transformed as a writer between draft one and two of the merger, and I learned the tone of the office real fast. Oh, Brent. Don't you love that? I just love that. I love that.
我们让事情在很长一段时间内保持戏剧性，我们主要从表演中获得喜剧效果。好吧，我在《合并》的第一稿和第二稿之间完成了作为编剧的蜕变，我很快就学会了《办公室》的基调。哦，布伦特。你不喜欢这个吗？我太喜欢了。我喜欢这个。
I was like, yeah, I got it wrong. They kind of like let me know what was what and then I gave it another try. Well what people should know is that Brent went on to be a co-executive producer of The Office. He ended up running the show with Paul Lieberstein. So he figured it out. He figured it out. Yeah, he did just fine.
我当时想，是的，我弄错了。他们让我知道什么是重点，然后我尝试了第二次。人们应该知道的是，布伦特后来成为了《办公室》的联合执行制片人。他最终和保罗·利伯斯坦一起负责该剧。所以他搞定了。他搞定了。是啊，他做得很好。
That's right. Okay, I'm so excited. We're going to have more clips from him figured it out. Yeah, he did just fine. That's right. OK, I'm so excited. We're going to have more clips from him coming up too. Yeah. Fast fact number three, let's talk about the transfers from Stanford. Yes, Stanford. Here are our new characters.
没错。好吧，我太兴奋了。我们会有更多他的片段……他搞定了。是啊，他做得很好。没错。好吧，我太兴奋了。我们会有更多他的片段。是啊。第三个快讯，让我们谈谈从斯坦福转来的员工。是的，斯坦福。这是我们的新角色。
We have Tony Gardner, played by Mike Bruner. We have Ursula Burton, who plays Hannah. And we have Wayne Wilderson, who plays Martin Nash. Now, you might recognize Mike Brunner, because he did have a small scene with Rashida in an earlier episode. Hannah was in the background of a few scenes over in Stanford. She had this storyline and some deleted scenes with Jim, but they had been cut.
我们有托尼·加德纳（Tony Gardner），由迈克·布鲁纳（Mike Bruner）饰演。我们有厄休拉·伯顿（Ursula Burton），饰演汉娜。我们有韦恩·怀尔德森（Wayne Wilderson），饰演马丁·纳什（Martin Nash）。现在，你可能认出迈克·布鲁纳，因为他在之前的一集中确实和拉什达（Rashida）有一个小场景。汉娜在斯坦福的几个场景背景中出现过。她有这条故事线和一些与吉姆的被删减片段，但它们被剪掉了。
And then you might recognize Wayne because he had a big recurring role on Veep. And by the way, now he's in Greg's new show Upload. Nice. And I want to take a tangent real quickly, Angela, to say that I'm really loving Upload. It is, uh, I know it's like sci-fi-y, but I'm super digging it because I realized something about my sci-fi thing. What? Okay.
然后你可能认出韦恩，因为他在《副总统》（Veep）中有一个重要的常驻角色。顺便说一下，他现在在格雷格的新剧《上载新生》（Upload）里。不错。我想快速跑个题，安吉拉，说我真的很喜欢《上载新生》。它是，呃，我知道它有点科幻，但我非常喜欢它，因为我意识到关于我的科幻爱好的一件事。什么？好吧。
I really like Black Mirror as well. And I feel like Upload has a type of sort of a comedic Black Mirror thing going on. And is that sci-fi? Is Black Mirror sci-fi fantasy? Yeah, I would say it is. It's a lot of like alternate realities and sort of, yeah, it is. I think it is.
我也真的很喜欢《黑镜》（Black Mirror）。我觉得《上载新生》有一种喜剧版的《黑镜》的感觉。那是科幻吗？《黑镜》是科幻奇幻吗？是啊，我会说是的。它有很多类似平行现实的东西，所以，是的，它是。我想它是。
Okay, is Handmaid's Tale sci-fi fantasy? Oh, gosh. See what I'm saying? This is the category that I like. I like a tiny spin. I love zombie movies. I love a tiny spin. I feel like zombie is horror though. I know, but I feel like it's falling in this new category that I want to designate, which is like it's some of life as we know it, and then some new rules.
好吧，《使女的故事》（Handmaid's Tale）是科幻奇幻吗？哦，天哪。你看我说的吧？这就是我喜欢的类别。我喜欢一点点转折。我喜欢僵尸电影。我喜欢一点点转折。我觉得僵尸是恐怖片。我知道，但我感觉它属于我想指定的一个新类别，就是它既有我们所知的生活，又有一些新规则。
Slightly altered reality. Altered reality. I'm doing a lot of gestures right now. You are. I wish you could see Jenna. She's like cupping the air and then like spinning it over her head like it's a world, a ball. I don't know what's happening. This is reality, and then this is altered reality. Here's the thing, Jenna. Handmaid's Tale, I don't think you can handle it. I watched it. It's fantastic.
稍微改变的现实。改变的现实。我现在做了很多手势。你确实做了。我希望你能看到珍娜。她像是在捧着空气，然后像把它像球一样在头顶旋转。我不知道发生了什么。这是现实，然后这是改变的现实。事情是这样的，珍娜。我不认为你能承受《使女的故事》。我看过。它太棒了。
I couldn't sleep at night. I was like, oh my gosh. Oh, I watched one episode of Handmaid's Tale, and I had nightmares for three nights. Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. And I've seen a lot of horror films, but that was, I mean, that got in my head.
我晚上睡不着觉。我当时想，哦，天哪。哦，我看了一集《使女的故事》，我做了三晚噩梦。哦，是啊。哦，是啊。我看过很多恐怖片，但那个，我的意思是，它钻进了我的脑子里。
Holy moly. OK, so. But here's what I'm saying. I feel like there is a tangent. Here's what I will not let go. I think there's a tangent of sci-fi that I'm super into, and it's altered reality sci-fi. OK.
天哪。好吧，所以。但这就是我要说的。我觉得有一个题外话。这是我不会放手的。我觉得有一种科幻是我非常喜欢的，那就是改变现实的科幻。好吧。
Fair enough, lady. Fair enough. Also, transfers that you have to mention are Karen Filippelli and Andy Bernard. Oh my gosh, of course. Yes. Yes. We have those guys coming over as well.
说得过去，女士。说得过去。另外，必须提到的转校生是凯伦·菲利帕里（Karen Filippelli）和安迪·伯纳德（Andy Bernard）。哦，天哪，当然。是的。是的。我们也有那些人过来。
So it's a total of five, a total of five new employees from Stanford that come to Scranton. We had a fan question from a lot of people. Okay. Jesse Kay, Seth Anderson, Connor McCulloch, and Molly Frank all asked, did the writers and cast know that Martin, Hannah, and Tony, those three of those five transfers were only temporary characters? Yes, we did.
所以总共有五个人，总共五个从斯坦福来的新员工来到斯克兰顿。我们收到了很多人的粉丝提问。好吧。杰西·凯（Jesse Kay）、塞斯·安德森（Seth Anderson）、康纳·麦卡洛克（Connor McCulloch）和莫莉·弗兰克（Molly Frank）都问，编剧和演员是否知道马丁、汉娜和托尼，这五个转校生中的三个只是临时角色？是的，我们知道。
We did, we didn't know how many episodes, right? But we knew they were gonna be part of this new wave that came over that Michael slowly alienates. We didn't know how many episodes, right? But we knew they were going to be part of this new wave that came over that Michael slowly alienates. Yes. I remember that there was a conversation that was after the merger, each week one of the new employees would quit until we were just left with Andy and Karen,
我们知道，我们不知道具体是多少集，对吧？但我们知道他们将成为这股新浪潮的一部分，迈克尔会慢慢疏远他们。我们不知道是多少集，对吧？但我们知道他们将成为这股新浪潮的一部分，迈克尔会慢慢疏远他们。是的。我记得当时有一次谈话，合并后，每周会有一名新员工辞职，直到我们只剩下安迪和凯伦，
are the two people who would stay. Hm. Yeah. All right, lady. maybe we should take a break and then let's get into this episode because I have a big catch right out of the gate in the cold open and I'm really excited to talk about it. All right, we will take a break on that
是留下的两个人。嗯。是啊。好吧，女士。也许我们应该休息一下，然后进入这一集，因为我在开场白中有一个大发现，我真的很兴奋谈论它。好吧，我们休息一下，
and we will be back with Angela's big catch. Big catch. Oh, wow. You gotta get that. This episode is brought to you by Dzone. For the first time ever, the 32 best soccer clubs from across the world are coming together to decide who the undisputed champions of the world are in the FIFA Club World Cup. The world's best players, Messi, Holland, Kane, and more are all taking part. And you can watch every match for free on Dazon, starting on June 14th and running until July 13th.
然后回来谈谈安吉拉的大发现。大发现。哦，哇。你一定要听听。本集由Dzone赞助。有史以来第一次，来自世界各地的32家最佳足球俱乐部齐聚一堂，在国际足联俱乐部世界杯上决定谁是无可争议的世界冠军。世界上最好的球员，梅西、哈兰德、凯恩等等都将参加。你可以从6月14日开始到7月13日，在Dazon上免费观看每一场比赛。
Sign up now at dazon.com slash FIFA. That's D-A-Z-N dot com slash FIFA. Hey, I'm Ben Stiller. And I'm Adam Scott. And we host a podcast called The Severance Podcast, where we used to break down every episode of the TV show Severance. Severance isn't back just yet, but the podcast is. Each week we'll discuss the movies, TV shows, and ideas that influence the making of Severance. We're going to talk to the incredible artists who inspire us to do what we do.
现在就在dazon.com/FIFA注册。那是D-A-Z-N点com斜杠FIFA。嘿，我是本·斯蒂勒（Ben Stiller）。我是亚当·斯科特（Adam Scott）。我们主持一个叫《Severance播客》的播客，我们过去常拆解电视剧《Severance》的每一集。《Severance》还没回归，但播客回归了。每周我们将讨论影响《Severance》制作的电影、电视节目和想法。我们将与激励我们做我们所做之事的杰出艺术家交谈。
The Severance Podcast returns Thursday, June 26. Follow and listen everywhere you get your podcasts. All right, guys, we're back. We start at the Stanford branch. Jim has a talking head. He tells us Stanford branch is closing. Andy made Stanford RIP hats for everyone. Andy asked Jim what Michael Scott is closing. Andy made Stanford RIP hats for everyone. Andy asked Jim what Michael Scott is like. Yeah, he wants some intel. He wants some intel.
《Severance播客》将于6月26日星期四回归。在任何你获取播客的地方关注并收听。好了，伙计们，我们回来了。我们从斯坦福分部开始。吉姆有一个谈话头。他告诉我们斯坦福分部要关闭了。安迪为每个人制作了斯坦福RIP帽子。安迪问吉姆迈克尔·斯科特是什么样的。是啊，他想要一些情报。他想要一些情报。
He wants to know how to work the system over there. Yeah, and Jim's like, you know what? You just kind of have to meet him. You have to meet him. But did you notice when Andy was asking him about Michael, he was like, what kind of magazines does he like? We know. We know what magazines.
他想知道如何在那边运作系统。是啊，吉姆说，你知道吗？你只需要去见他。你必须去见他。但你注意到当安迪问他关于迈克尔的事时，他说，他喜欢什么样的杂志？我们知道。我们知道是什么杂志。
American Way, Kraft. Yeah, he loves American Way. If Jim had given Andy the list of magazines, would that have helped Andy? I feel like if someone gave me Michael's list of magazines, I would be like, I am even more confused about this person. I am intrigued. Who is this person?
《美国之路》（American Way）、《卡夫》（Kraft）。是啊，他喜欢《美国之路》。如果吉姆给了安迪杂志清单，那会对安迪有帮助吗？我觉得如果有人给了我迈克尔的杂志清单，我会觉得，我对这个人更加困惑了。我很好奇。这个人是谁？
So then Jim and Karen, they have a little moment. They agree this is going to be a big adventure. Karen gives Jim a real flirty flirt look, but Jim doesn't see it, right? But like, she's pining. Her heart is a flutter. They high five. I think, I feel like Karen flirts and then Jim high fives,
然后吉姆和凯伦，他们有了一个小瞬间。他们同意这将是一次大冒险。凯伦给了吉姆一个真正的调情眼神，但吉姆没看到，对吧？但就像，她在渴望。她的心在颤动。他们击掌。我想，我觉得凯伦在调情，然后吉姆击掌，
which for any woman that's into a guy, if you flirt a little and like maybe cut some eyes at him and you get a high five, it's like, beeper. I'm like, Karen, there are so many signs here. Don't do it. We're gonna get into something I've started tracking called wishy washy Jim.
对于任何对男人感兴趣的女人来说，如果你调情一点，也许对他抛个媚眼，然后你得到一个击掌，这就像是，哔哔。我当时想，凯伦，这里有这么多信号。别做。我们要进入我开始追踪的一个叫“优柔寡断的吉姆”的话题。
Oh, well, welcome. Welcome to the club. I mean, he's been wishy-washy for a long time. Yeah, but he does a lot of super big wishy-washies in this episode. All right. Now we're back in Scranton. Toby has come up to Pam at reception, and he's talking about how he completed his run.
哦，好吧，欢迎。欢迎加入俱乐部。我的意思是，他已经优柔寡断很久了。是啊，但他在这一集中做了很多超级大的优柔寡断。好了。现在我们回到斯克兰顿。托比来到前台找帕姆，他正在谈论他是如何完成跑步的。
And I have a catch! Oh, and is this what you teased us about before the break? This is what I teach you about. It's now I've set it up. It is going to be so lame. But at a minute six seconds, new plant alert, Angela alert at front reception. You have a friend in Hadley Lock who wrote in to say, Angela, is that a new tree at Pam's desk? Hadley, it is a new plant.
我有一个发现！哦，这就是你在休息前卖关子的那个吗？这就是我卖关子的那个。现在我已经铺垫好了。这会很无聊。但在第6分钟06秒，新植物警报，安吉拉警报，在前台。你有一个朋友哈德利·洛克（Hadley Lock）写信说，安吉拉，那是帕姆桌上的一棵新树吗？哈德利，那是一棵新植物。
It's in a maroon ceramic pot. Like not just like, usually Pam's plants are just in like that plastic crap that comes from the store. You know what I mean? Yeah. This isn't an actual pot. But Hadley, my friend Hadley, did you see what happens to the plant later in the episode?
它在一个栗色的陶瓷盆里。不像，通常帕姆的植物只是在那种商店买来的塑料垃圾里。你知道我的意思吗？是啊。这不是一个真正的盆。但哈德利，我的朋友哈德利，你看到植物在这一集后面发生了什么吗？
What happens? Where does it go? Hadley, did you notice that at a minute, six seconds, there's the one plant? But then go to five minutes, 25 seconds. It's a totally different plant. What? Whatever plant we used in
发生了什么？它去哪了？哈德利，你注意到在第6分钟06秒，有一棵植物吗？但去到第5分钟25秒。那是完全不同的植物。什么？无论我们在
the cold open, I don't know what happened to it. They couldn't find it. Someone got a different plant. It is a different plant. The plant at a minute, six seconds is like small light green leaves. And then at five minutes, 25, it's the big dark green kind of leaves. And it's in a different pot holder. It's in like the clay looking pot holder, whereas at a minute six seconds it's like a shiny maroon pot holder. Guys, I know this is what you're here for, but this is some serious plant gate. Plant gate! You have found the evidence for something I was wondering about. I think we filmed this cold open on another day. evidence for something I was wondering about. I think we filmed this cold open on another day.
开场白中用了什么植物，我不知道它发生了什么。他们找不到它了。有人拿了另一棵植物。那是不同的植物。第6分钟06秒的植物是那种小浅绿色的叶子。然后在5分25秒，它是那种大深绿色的叶子。而且它在不同的盆托里。它在那种看起来像粘土的盆托里，而在6分06秒它像是闪亮的栗色盆托。伙计们，我知道这就是你们来这里的原因，但这可是严重的“植物门”。植物门！你发现了我想知道的事情的证据。我想我们是在另一天拍摄这个开场白的。
Oh, I think we inserted this cold open that it wasn't in the original shooting draft. So I think we came back and did this whole Dwight Toby running thing at a different time. And that's why the plants are different. Yes, that would make sense. They knew there was a plant on your desk, but they couldn't get the same one. So they just had to budget. Okay, because here's the thing. Pam takes Dwight down to the parking lot, right? Because he says that he can run faster than Toby, faster than anything. He's not impressed with Toby's running time. Jenna, he can run faster than a snake, a mongoose, and a panther somewhere in there. That's his speed. Right. So Pam is like, all right, I'm going to time you.
哦，我想我们插入了这个开场白，它不在最初的拍摄草稿中。所以我认为我们回来在不同的时间做了整个德怀特和托比跑步的事情。这就是为什么植物不同。是的，那说得通。他们知道你桌上有棵植物，但他们找不到同一棵。所以他们只能凑合。好吧，因为事情是这样的，帕姆带德怀特下到停车场，对吧？因为他说他跑得比托比快，比任何东西都快。他对托比的跑步时间印象不深。珍娜，他跑得比蛇、猫鼬和豹子都快。那是他的速度。没错。所以帕姆说，好吧，我要给你计时。
And she makes Dwight run around the building. She's holding a digital thermometer. She has this sort of long kind of sort of a talking head. She's kind of talking out loud, talking to the documentary crew. And then she just goes inside. She abandons Dwight. He's kind of talking out loud, talking to the documentary crew. And then she just goes inside. She abandons Dwight. We had fan questions from Spencer Brandon, Mateus Almeida, and Angie T. Does Reign actually
她让德怀特绕着大楼跑。她拿着一个数字温度计。她有这种长长的，某种谈话头。她有点在大声说话，对着纪录片摄制组说话。然后她就进去了。她抛弃了德怀特。她有点在大声说话，对着纪录片摄制组说话。然后她就进去了。她抛弃了德怀特。我们收到了来自斯宾塞·布兰登（Spencer Brandon）、马修斯·阿尔梅达（Mateus Almeida）和安吉·T（Angie T）的粉丝提问。雷恩（Rainn）真的
run around the whole building in the cold open? How did they time it out for Dwight to be running around the corner just as Pam finished talking? All right, Angela, I watched the scene. It is a one-shot. There is no cut. So did Rain really have to run around the building? Well, you reached out to Ken Whittingham, right?
在开场白中绕着整栋大楼跑了吗？他们是如何安排时间让德怀特在帕姆说完话时刚好跑过拐角的？好吧，安吉拉，我看了那个场景。这是一个长镜头。没有剪辑。所以雷恩真的必须绕着大楼跑吗？好吧，你联系了肯·惠廷汉姆，对吧？
And you asked him what he remembered. And he said he did not film this cold open. No, which again is further evidence to you that we filmed it on a different day. So someone else had to direct just this cold open because it was an insert, right? Yes. I was trying to remember shooting the scene and I have a memory that yes, the reason I'm talking kind of so slowly is because Rain really had to run. Yet at the same time, I didn't think he ran around the whole building. So I reached out to Rain.
你问他记得什么。他说他没有拍摄这个开场白。不，这再次证明了你，我们是在不同的一天拍摄的。所以必须有别人来执导这个开场白，因为它是一个插入镜头，对吧？是的。我试着回忆拍摄那个场景，我有一个记忆，是的，我说话之所以这么慢，是因为雷恩真的必须跑。但同时，我不认为他绕着整栋大楼跑了。所以我联系了雷恩。
And? Rain said he cut through the warehouse. That's smart. So if you notice, the camera pans to me and he cut through the warehouse, through the building to the door on the other side and then he ran around the corner. So he was still running a significant amount. Here's what I also thought when I watched that is once again, Pam has become the gem of this office. She's the prankster now. She's timing him with a thermometer, making him
然后呢？雷恩说他穿过了仓库。那很聪明。所以如果你注意到，摄像机转向我，他穿过了仓库，穿过大楼到了另一边的门，然后他绕过了拐角。所以他仍然跑了相当多的距离。这就是我观看时想到的，帕姆再次成为了这个办公室的宝石。她现在是恶作剧者了。她用温度计给他计时，让他
run around the building. Pam is Jim. Oh, I bet she can't wait to tell Jim what she did when he finally gets there. Too bad he's not going to want to hang out with her, sorry. He doesn't engage. Well, we'll get to that. We'll get to that. All right, so now here it is.
绕着大楼跑。帕姆就是吉姆。哦，我敢打赌她迫不及待地想告诉吉姆她做了什么，当他终于到达时。可惜他不会想和她待在一起，抱歉。他不参与。好吧，我们会谈到的。我们会谈到的。好了，现在就是这样。
Dwight and Michael, they're prepping the office for the new arrivals. They're going around, they're putting name tags for everyone. There's gift bags. I have to think the party planning committee had to stuff those bags with pencils and coupons. You know, I wanted to discuss the gift bags, Angela, because I thought they were a really nice gesture. I think they are too. I, you know, I sort of appreciate we have to go out of town a lot for work. I always appreciate when the film company or the television company, they'll put a little binder full of local restaurants and attractions for me to come through as I am now about to spend two months in this location that I don't know.
德怀特和迈克尔，他们正在为新来的人准备办公室。他们四处走动，为每个人贴上名牌。还有礼品袋。我不得不认为派对策划委员会必须在那些袋子里塞满铅笔和优惠券。你知道，我想讨论一下礼品袋，安吉拉，因为我觉得这是一个非常好的姿态。我也觉得是。我，你知道，我有点感激我们经常要出差工作。我总是很感激当电影公司或电视公司，他们会放一个装满当地餐馆和景点的小活页夹给我，因为我即将在这个我不了解的地方待上两个月。
I think it's lovely to offer people little local coupons, suggestions of where to eat. Very thoughtful Nifty Gifty bag. Very thoughtful. I'm the type of person if I check into a hotel and they give me a bottled water, I'm like, thank you. I don't know. I love small gestures and I think this is really sweet. I do too.
我觉得提供给人们一些当地优惠券、吃饭建议是非常可爱的。非常贴心的“精美礼品袋”。非常贴心。我是那种人，如果我入住酒店，他们给我一瓶水，我会说，谢谢。我不知道。我喜欢小姿态，我觉得这真的很甜。我也觉得。
And I feel like it just doesn't get the sort of appreciation that it should. The Nifty Gifty bag, I thought it was very thoughtful of Michael. Also, I want to start using Nifty Gifty. That is a fantastic phrase. Nifty Gifties. Nifty Gifties. Nifty Gifties. Okay.
我觉得它没有得到它应该得到的赞赏。精美礼品袋，我觉得迈克尔非常贴心。另外，我想开始使用“精美礼品”这个词。这是一个很棒的短语。精美礼品。精美礼品。精美礼品。好吧。
So as they're walking around prepping the office, Dwight suggests Michael fire Anthony Gardner before noon to consolidate power. But Michael's like, I'm not going to do that, Dwight. I'm not going to do that. But he's planting the seeds. Someone must go today. Yeah. Okay.
所以当他们四处走动准备办公室时，德怀特建议迈克尔在中午之前解雇安东尼·加德纳（Anthony Gardner）以巩固权力。但迈克尔说，我不会那样做，德怀特。我不会那样做。但他正在播下种子。今天必须有人走。好吧。
So at four minutes, Pam enters in. She's carrying food. Michael asked her to set it all up in the conference room. Jenna, you're holding two really big grocery bags. Yeah. And I have what I like, I have what I'm gonna start calling a random prop alert. Yep.
所以四分钟时，帕姆进来了。她带着食物。迈克尔让她把所有东西都放在会议室里。珍娜，你拿着两个非常大的购物袋。是啊，我有我喜欢的东西，我有我开始称之为“随机道具警报”的东西。没错。
Jenna, you know the story behind those bags. Oh yeah. You and I both know. Those are fakey bags. They're fakey bags, guys. They're fakey bags. Here. They're fakey bags. Here's what we mean. Those bags, they're made of this material that won't make any crinkly noises.
珍娜，你知道那些袋子背后的故事。哦，是的。你和我都清楚。那是“假袋子”。它们是假袋子，伙计们。它们是假袋子。在这里。它们是假袋子。这就是我们的意思。那些袋子，它们是用这种不会发出任何皱褶声音的材料做的。
Yeah. It's super weird. It's almost like a fabric, but it's really stiff. Yeah. That's what she said. How would you describe it? I don't know how to describe it. It's like. It is.
是啊。超级奇怪。它几乎像是一种织物，但它非常硬。是啊。这就是她说的。你会怎么描述它？我不知道怎么描述它。它就像。它是。
It's sort of like a stiff fabric felt exterior. But as soon as you spot one, you'll spot them in every show you ever watch. I'm telling you guys, any show you're watching where someone goes to the store and comes in with anything that looks like a grocery bag, it's the fakey bag. Yeah.
它有点像硬织物毡的外观。但一旦你发现一个，你会在你看过的每一部剧中发现它们。我告诉你们，伙计们，任何你正在看的剧中，有人去商店并带着任何看起来像购物袋的东西进来，那都是假袋子。是啊。
Because the real bags make too much sound for the sound engineers, for the boom operators. So the props department came up with these kind of fake bags and every single TV show uses them. You'll see, you'll see. They fascinate me. The first time someone handed one to me, I was like, what is this item?
因为真正的袋子对音响工程师、对吊杆操作员来说声音太大了。所以道具部门想出了这些假袋子，每一部电视剧都使用它们。你会看到的，你会看到的。它们让我着迷。第一次有人递给我一个时，我当时想，这是什么东西？
What is this made of? This fabric-y, stiff, filthy, fake grocery bag. Yeah, yeah. I'm always fascinated by them. And you're right, once you see it, you can't unsee it. You can't unsee it because the brown paper bag, it doesn't look like paper. Look closely, it doesn't, you're like, hmm, what is that?
这是什么做的？这种织物状的、硬的、肮脏的、假的购物袋。是啊，是啊。我总是被它们迷住。你是对的，一旦你看到了，你就无法忽视它。你无法忽视它，因为棕色纸袋，它看起来不像纸。仔细看，它不是，你会想，嗯，那是什么？
You'll see it. You'll see it. Also, there's never any printing on it. There's never any name of grocery store. It's just this solid brown bag. So next, Pam has her talking head, and she's excited to meet all the new people. She's excited to see her old friend. She's definitely in a good mood. We had some fan questions. Okay. Alice64, Jessica Scott, Harrison Perez, Amy Ardilla, and Jamie Kearns all asked about Pam's hair. They noted that Pam's hairstyle changes
你会看到的。你会看到的。而且，上面从来没有任何印刷字样。从来没有杂货店的名字。它只是一个纯棕色的袋子。接下来，帕姆进行了她的单人访谈，她很兴奋能见到所有的新人。她很兴奋能见到她的老朋友。她的心情非常好。我们收到了一些粉丝提问。好的。Alice64、Jessica Scott、Harrison Perez、Amy Ardilla 和 Jamie Kearns 都问到了帕姆的头发。他们注意到帕姆的发型变了
from the little smaller scrunchie curls to bigger, smoother curls. They wanted to know if this was intentional for Jim's return. Oh yeah. Oh yeah. For sure. Someone zhuzhed it up and then decided to wear a sweater
从那种小一点的发圈卷发变成了更大、更顺滑的卷发。他们想知道这是否是为了吉姆的回归而特意设计的。哦，是的。哦，是的。当然。有人把它打理了一下，然后决定穿上一件
that her mom made her, because that's how you zhuzh up when your fellas coming. Let me get that sweater my mom knitted me with the extra big button right in the middle. The button is so huge. All right, Angela, Maggie Mendez, Diana Swanson, and Morgan Ostrag all asked, is Pam's sweater really homemade? No, look at it.
她妈妈给她做的毛衣，因为这就是你迎接男朋友时打扮自己的方式。让我穿上我妈给我织的那件中间有个超大扣子的毛衣。那个扣子太大了。好了，安吉拉，Maggie Mendez、Diana Swanson 和 Morgan Ostrag 都问，帕姆的毛衣真的是自制的吗？不，看看它。
No. I thought they could have done a better job of finding you a sweater that looked a little bit more homemade. Well, that was a store-bought sweater. They did alter it a little bit to try to make it look homemade. The giant button was an ad. Oh, well, great job. Oh my gosh, I am not throwing shade.
不。我觉得他们本可以做得更好，找一件看起来更像自制的毛衣给你。嗯，那是一件商店买的毛衣。他们确实稍微改动了一下，试图让它看起来像自制的。那个巨大的扣子是后来加的。哦，好吧，干得好。天哪，我不是在贬低它。
I'm just saying. The sweater was hilarious. And to me, it's just... Listen, listen, the wardrobe department did not have time to knit me a sweater. I mean, they got the script. What are they going to do? I guess they could have tried to find some homemade sweaters. We did try a bunch on, but here was the other thing.
我只是随口一说。那件毛衣太搞笑了。对我来说，这只是……听着，听着，服装部门没时间给我织毛衣。我是说，他们拿到了剧本。他们能做什么？我想他们本可以试着找一些自制的毛衣。我们确实试穿了很多件，但还有一件事。
They wanted the sweater to be flattering, you know, like they wanted Pam to look cute for Jim. And so this was our compromise, a store-bought sweater that we altered a little. Mom, I need you to knit me a sexy sweater. Exactly. It has to be sexy, Mom. And only one button, please. Now here's something no one brought up,
他们想让这件毛衣看起来显身材，你知道，他们想让帕姆在吉姆面前看起来很可爱。所以这就是我们的折中方案，一件稍微改动过的商店买的毛衣。妈妈，我需要你给我织一件性感的毛衣。没错。它必须是性感的，妈妈。而且只有一个扣子，拜托。现在有一件事没人提过，
but I totally noticed. Purple eyeshadow? Oh. Purpley eyeshadow and a little gloss on the lips. Well, I noticed the gloss, but clearly all I notice are lips these days. So that's where you're at, Anne. That's where I'm at.
但我完全注意到了。紫色眼影？哦。紫色的眼影，嘴唇上涂了一点唇彩。嗯，我注意到了唇彩，但显然我最近只注意嘴唇了。所以这就是你的状态，安。这就是我的状态。
Well, you know, the new transfers start to arrive. And Jenna, we like to track things. I just want you to know, I tracked, and Michael insults every single person except for Andy. Yes, we have a series of racist and sexist microaggressions courtesy of Michael Scott. Here they are. He tells Hannah her ball and chain is over here.
嗯，你知道，新调来的人开始到了。珍娜，我们喜欢追踪一些事情。我只想让你知道，我追踪了，迈克尔侮辱了除了安迪之外的每一个人。是的，我们有一系列由迈克尔·斯科特提供的种族主义和性别歧视的微攻击。它们在这里。他告诉汉娜，她的“拖油瓶”在这里。
He calls Tony Gardner the big guy. He tells Karen she looks exotic and asks if her father was a GI. And then he tells Martin Nash that he will show him where all the slaves work. Yes. Michael manages to find a way to start everyone's first day with a completely inappropriate comment.
他称托尼·加德纳为“大块头”。他告诉凯伦她看起来很有异国情调，并问她的父亲是不是美国大兵。然后他告诉马丁·纳什，他会带他去看所有奴隶工作的地方。是的。迈克尔总能找到方法，用完全不恰当的评论开启每个人的第一天。
Michael, Michael! Well, Pam can't do her trick where Michael gets the redo. You know how Pam doesn't put a call through the first time because his first instinct is always the wrong instinct. Yes. Hannah arrives first. Michael shows her to her desk. Yes. And he walks her to her desk and they walk past accounting. Four minutes, 41 seconds. Kevin is at his desk, but Angela is not. I mean, I feel like, what? Kevin made it to work before Angela? Just saying. Angela's running? Kevin made it to work before Angela? Hmm. Just saying.
迈克尔，迈克尔！好吧，帕姆不能再用她那招让迈克尔重来的把戏了。你知道帕姆是怎么做的，她第一次不会转接电话，因为他的第一直觉总是错误的直觉。是的。汉娜先到了。迈克尔带她去她的办公桌。是的。他带她走到办公桌，他们经过了会计部。4分41秒。凯文在办公桌前，但安吉拉不在。我是说，我觉得，什么？凯文比安吉拉先到公司？只是随口一说。安吉拉在跑步？凯文比安吉拉先到公司？嗯。只是随口一说。
Angela's running a little late today. Where's Angela? Where is Angela? I don't know. All right. So, Tony Gardner is the next to arrive. And guess who's standing right there? Who?
安吉拉今天迟到了一点。安吉拉在哪儿？安吉拉在哪儿？我不知道。好吧。那么，托尼·加德纳是下一个到的。你猜谁正站在那儿？谁？
Hannah. What? Didn't she just get walked to her desk? How is she now back at reception? Why isn't she at her desk? Hmm. I think this is a continuity error. I didn't notice it. just get walked to her desk? How is she now back at reception? Why isn't she at her desk? I think this is a continuity error. I didn't notice it, but in hearing it, I'm going to have to agree with you. Yeah, all of a sudden she's right back. Now Karen arrives and her and Pam, they kind of immediately hit it off. There's like some nice
汉娜。什么？她不是刚被带到办公桌吗？她怎么现在又回到前台了？她为什么不在她的办公桌前？嗯。我觉得这是一个连续性错误。我没注意到。刚被带到办公桌吗？她怎么现在又回到前台了？她为什么不在她的办公桌前？我觉得这是一个连续性错误。我没注意到，但听你这么一说，我不得不赞同你。是的，她突然又回来了。现在凯伦到了，她和帕姆，她们似乎立刻就合得来了。有一些不错的
banter. If not for Jim, Pam would finally have a friend in the office, right? She would have another woman around her age who is nice to her. Yeah, who she can have a conversation with. Because I think Kelly is nice to you, but Kelly just wants to talk about Brad Pitt and Angelina Jolie's baby.
玩笑。如果不是因为吉姆，帕姆终于可以在办公室里有个朋友了，对吧？她会有另一个和她年龄相仿、对她友好的女性。是的，可以和她聊天的人。因为我觉得凯莉对你很好，但凯莉只想谈论布拉德·皮特和安吉丽娜·朱莉的孩子。
Yeah, I guess that's true. Kelly is nice to Pam, but they don't have a lot in common. Karen is someone she could actually be friends with. But nope, no, it's not going to happen. No. So then we have Andy's talking head down in the parking lot. He's about to arrive. And I love this talking head.
是的，我想那是真的。凯莉对帕姆很好，但她们没有太多共同点。凯伦是她真正可以成为朋友的人。但不行，不，这不会发生的。不。所以接下来是安迪在停车场进行的单人访谈。他快要到了。我喜欢这个单人访谈。
He says he plans to be the number two in Scranton within weeks. He lays out his game plan. Here's what it includes. Repetition, personality mirroring, and never breaking off a handshake. He says you always have to think one step ahead like a carpenter who makes stairs. I wanna discuss this.
他说他计划在几周内成为斯克兰顿的二把手。他制定了他的行动计划。内容包括：重复、个性镜像，以及永远不要中断握手。他说你必须像做楼梯的木匠一样，永远比别人多想一步。我想讨论一下这个。
I think this is a really good strategy. I kinda wanna discuss this. I think this is a really good strategy. I kind of want to try it. No, no, Jenna, I don't see this going well. Don't, I don't know. You can't like walk up to someone and just start imitating how they talk and their movements. I don't know. I mean, I think it's personality mirroring. Is that an actual thing? Is that taught at leadership seminars somewhere? Because it feels, this feels very much like Andy went
我觉得这是一个非常好的策略。我有点想讨论一下这个。我觉得这是一个非常好的策略。我有点想尝试一下。不，不，珍娜，我不觉得这会顺利。别，我不知道。你不能走到某人面前，就开始模仿他们说话的方式和动作。我不知道。我是说，我觉得这是个性镜像。这是真实存在的东西吗？这是在某个领导力研讨会上教的吗？因为感觉，这感觉非常像安迪去了
to a leadership seminar and they're like, here's how you make a good first impression. Say their name a whole bunch. Yeah, name repetition. Never break a handshake. I don't know, Ange. Can we try it? I'm gonna meet you, okay?
一个领导力研讨会，他们说，这是你给人留下良好第一印象的方法。多说几次他们的名字。是的，名字重复。永远不要中断握手。我不知道，安吉。我们可以试试吗？我要认识你，好吗？
Go ahead. I'm gonna be Andy. Go. Hi. Hey. How are you? I'm good. How are you, Angela? I haven't told you my name yet, creeper. How'd you know it was me? Have you been stalking me, psycho? I googled you before our meeting. Okay, I'm out. You know what? This is not going well. I'm out.
来吧。我要当安迪。开始。嗨。嘿。你好吗？我很好。你好吗，安吉拉？我还没告诉你我的名字呢，变态。你怎么知道是我？你一直在跟踪我吗，神经病？我在我们见面之前谷歌了你。好吧，我退出了。你知道吗？这进行得不顺利。我退出了。
I'm out. I'm out. I failed. I did a terrible job. You failed in three sentences. Oh boy. All right. Maybe not.
我退出了。我退出了。我失败了。我做得太糟糕了。你在三句话之内就失败了。哦，天哪。好吧。也许不行。
Okay. Okay. So Andy arrives. He gets his nifty gifties and he does his strategy and Michael loves it. Yes. Michael thinks he's awesome because Andy is doing impression of Michael. So Michael probably feels like he gets me. Yeah, he loves it. We had a fan catch Angela.
好的。好的。所以安迪到了。他拿出了他的小礼物，他执行了他的策略，迈克尔很喜欢。是的。迈克尔认为他很棒，因为安迪在模仿迈克尔。所以迈克尔可能觉得他懂我。是的，他很喜欢。我们有一个粉丝捕捉到了，安吉拉。
Oh. Veronica Ramirez noted that when Andy was in the parking lot doing his talking head, he has his tan jacket on. Yeah. But when he walks through the door, it's nowhere to be seen. Oh. Where did he take off his jacket? Where did he put his jacket? He left it with that other plant.
哦。Veronica Ramirez 指出，当安迪在停车场进行单人访谈时，他穿着那件棕褐色夹克。是的。但当他走进门时，它不见了。哦。他把夹克脱在哪儿了？他把夹克放哪儿了？他把它和那株植物放在一起了。
There's in a warehouse somewhere. In a box of lost things. Yeah. Oh my gosh. Guess who's making his big debut? Jim. He walks in with Martin. They're talking sports. Pam about does a cartwheel to get to him. And hugs him. Leaps into his arms, really.
在仓库的某个地方。在一个装满丢失物品的盒子里。是的。天哪。猜猜谁要隆重登场了？吉姆。他和马丁一起走进来。他们在谈论体育。帕姆差点为了走到他身边而翻了个跟头。并拥抱了他。真的跳进了他的怀里。
Yeah, I was going to say, this is not just a hug. She like, she throws herself on him. Yeah. But can I say something? Say it. Seven minutes, 27 seconds. I have a giant zit next to my chin, and they have tried to cover it up, but it's like a little bit like when you try to cover up like super big zits. This is one of those zits.
是的，我正想说，这不仅仅是一个拥抱。她就像，她扑向了他。是的。但我能说点什么吗？说吧。7分27秒。我的下巴旁边有一个巨大的痘痘，他们试图遮住它，但这有点像当你试图遮住超大痘痘时的样子。这就是其中之一。
And I honestly remember it, believe it or not. And when I saw it, I was like, oh yeah, I remember that. It's one of those zits that feels like it's throbbing on your face. Yeah, it's a zit that has a heartbeat. That's what I call it, it has a heartbeat. And you can't squeeze it because it's so underground, but it's like a beacon shining off your face.
我真的记得它，信不信由你。当我看到它时，我就想，哦，是的，我记得那个。它是那种感觉在脸上跳动的痘痘。是的，这是一个有心跳的痘痘。我就是这么叫它的，它有心跳。你不能挤它，因为它太深了，但它就像一个在你脸上闪烁的灯塔。
And here it was, we had to film this scene where Pam is going to see Jim for the first time. And I was like, I cannot believe we're dealing with this today. And the makeup department, I mean, they did their best. They caked a bunch of makeup on it. But it is there. There's always so much you can do. There's only so much.
就在这里，我们必须拍摄帕姆第一次见到吉姆的场景。我当时想，我简直不敢相信我们今天在处理这个。化妆部门，我是说，他们尽力了。他们在上面涂了一层厚厚的化妆品。但它还在那里。总是有很多你能做的。只有这么多。
And it's there. Yeah. And it still bums me out today. It's OK, lady. I had a big zit in the Valentine's episode. And all the photos we took, remember we did, it was like a whole cross photo day. There's like photos of me looking up
它还在那里。是的。直到今天它还让我感到沮丧。没关系，女士。我在情人节那集里也有一个大痘痘。我们拍的所有照片，记得我们做的吗，那就像是一个完整的交叉照片日。有我抬头看着
at Dwight, this like Valentine's photo, and I have an enormous zit. So, you know. I can't remember what episode it is, but I'm going to ask Greg, because there was a future episode that was like a huge Jim Pam thing. And I had another one of these big zits. And then when I saw the episode, it was gone.
德怀特的照片，这张情人节照片，我有一个巨大的痘痘。所以，你知道。我不记得是哪一集了，但我会问格雷格，因为未来有一集就像是一个巨大的吉姆帕姆情节。我又长了另一个这种大痘痘。然后当我看到那一集时，它不见了。
And I swear I was like, Greg, what happened? He said, you know what, Jenna, we decided to take it out and post. Oh, good God. We CGI'd your zit away because it was really distracting. How embarrassing, Jenna, that there was a room full of people that you didn't even know who had to have a conversation about, do we have it in the budget, to scoochie out her zit in post edit?
我发誓我当时想，格雷格，发生了什么？他说，你知道吗，珍娜，我们决定在后期把它去掉。哦，天哪。你们用CGI去掉了我的痘痘，因为它真的很让人分心。多尴尬啊，珍娜，有一个房间的人你甚至都不认识，他们不得不讨论，我们预算里有钱在后期处理掉她的痘痘吗？
And then it was someone's job to painstakingly remove it frame by frame. Yeah, it was so's job to painstakingly remove it frame by frame. Yeah, it was so distracting. Oh, Lord. Well, Jenna, you're not alone. Hadley, who also noticed the plant, wrote in and said, at the talking head at three minutes, 55 seconds, does Dwight have a little pimple on his right cheek? Now, why were we all so pimply in this episode? Was it the summer? Were we just all hot and sweaty? I don't know. Maybe so. All right. So Jim now enters and Dwight and Jim are reunited. Jim messes with Dwight immediately by pretending like he's meeting his eyeline,
然后某人的工作就是费力地逐帧移除它。是的，这太让人分心了。哦，天哪。好吧，珍娜，你并不孤单。Hadley，他也注意到了那株植物，写信说，在3分55秒的单人访谈中，德怀特的右脸颊上是不是有一个小痘痘？为什么我们在这一集里都长了这么多痘痘？是夏天吗？我们是不是都又热又出汗？我不知道。也许是吧。好吧。所以吉姆现在进来了，德怀特和吉姆重逢了。吉姆立刻通过假装他在对视来戏弄德怀特，
even though he's not. Yeah, Jim and Dwight are right back at it. And if you guys love to track a really good John Krasinski DeWyte, go to 7 minutes 53 seconds. Oh, nice. It's a really good, hi, DeWyte. Nice. So everyone has arrived now. And we had a fan question. A lot of people wrote in.
即使他没有。是的，吉姆和德怀特又开始了。如果你们喜欢追踪一个非常好的约翰·卡拉辛斯基的“德怀特”，请看7分53秒。哦，不错。这是一个非常好的，嗨，德怀特。不错。所以现在每个人都到了。我们有一个粉丝提问。很多人写信来。
Kristin F, Sarah Hodges, Connor McCulloch, Erica Sansom, and more all wanted to know what was it like having all these new actors on set from the Stanford branch? And what was it like to have John back? I wrote about this in my journal. Of course you did. Of course you journaled this. I said, we were really excited to shoot the merger. It was like we were meeting new people.
Kristin F、Sarah Hodges、Connor McCulloch、Erica Sansom 等人都想知道，让所有这些来自斯坦福分部的新演员在片场是什么感觉？让约翰回来是什么感觉？我在我的日记里写过这个。你当然写了。你当然记录了这个。我说，我们真的很兴奋能拍摄合并。就像我们在见新朋友一样。
The Stanford and Scranton branches shot on different days and different sound stages. So we almost never were together except for maybe just a few times. And we all really missed John's presence on set. So when the branches merged, it was the first time we were all acting together as a group. And it was a blast. Ed Helms made me laugh so loud, I pulled the phyllis and snorted. Oh, I love that. Yeah, it was great. It was great to have this new energy and new people. And I just have such fun memories of it. Yeah. I will tell you the place where I snort laughed
斯坦福和斯克兰顿分部是在不同的日子和不同的摄影棚拍摄的。所以我们几乎从不在一起，除了可能只有几次。我们所有人都非常想念约翰在片场的存在。所以当分部合并时，这是我们第一次作为一个整体一起演戏。这太棒了。艾德·赫尔姆斯让我笑得太大声了，我像菲利斯一样喷了出来。哦，我喜欢那个。是的，这太棒了。拥有这种新的能量和新的人真是太棒了。我对此有非常有趣的回忆。是的。我会告诉你我喷笑的地方
when we get to it. OK, good. I wrote a little note. Can we talk for a second about one of my two favorite scenes in this episode? Yes. It is the Ryan-Jim desk dance. Oh, yeah?
当我们讲到那里时。好的，很好。我写了一个小笔记。我们能谈谈这一集中我最喜欢的两个场景之一吗？是的。那就是瑞安和吉姆的办公桌之舞。哦，是吗？
Where they both set their bags down on the same chair. Yeah. I love it so much. They're both doing that sort of like polite thing, like, oh, I'm sorry, are you, was this you, you're sitting here now or did you? And then Ryan ends up getting the desk and I love his talking head so much.
他们俩把包放在同一把椅子上。是的。我太喜欢了。他们俩都在做那种礼貌的事情，比如，哦，对不起，你是，这是你，你现在坐在这里还是你？然后瑞安最终得到了办公桌，我太喜欢他的单人访谈了。
I talked a little bit about this with BJ, where I said, as an older person, I am looking back on the office and I'm super loving the character of Ryan. I don't know what it is. I think maybe when you get older, you just, you give zero more often. And I feel like Ryan gives zero.
我和BJ谈过一点这个，我说，作为一个年长的人，我正在回顾《办公室》，我超级喜欢瑞安这个角色。我不知道为什么。我想也许当你变老时，你只是，你更频繁地不在乎了。我觉得瑞安就是不在乎。
I feel like you're, you're connecting with Ryan because you feel like you finally aged to his place of zero Fs. Exactly. I think that's what it is. And I just love his talking head. And he's like, yeah, Jim's a nice guy. That's why I got the desk. Yeah.
我觉得你，你和瑞安产生了共鸣，因为你觉得你终于老到了他那种“零在乎”的境界。没错。我想就是这样。我太喜欢他的单人访谈了。他说，是的，吉姆是个好人。这就是为什么我得到了办公桌。是的。
And I'm like, that's so funny. Okay, I want to say something. In the script, there was a different talking head. Oh, what was it? So that talking head that made it in was an alt. The talking head in the original script, Ryan was supposed to say, why? Because this is Ryan's desk now.
我当时想，那太搞笑了。好的，我想说点什么。在剧本里，有一个不同的单人访谈。哦，是什么？所以那个最终播出的单人访谈是一个备选。在原始剧本的单人访谈中，瑞安应该说，为什么？因为这是瑞安现在的办公桌。
Oh, I like the one that made it in better. Me too. Me too. I like the alt. It's more layered. Yeah. More layered. Well, Jenna, up next is a pretty big moment
哦，我更喜欢最终播出的那个。我也是。我也是。我喜欢那个备选。它更有层次感。是的。更有层次感。好吧，珍娜，接下来是一个相当大的时刻
for the characters of the show, because we have two adversaries meeting at 9 minutes, 7 seconds, Dwight and Andy. Yeah. Neither will break the handshake. That handshake goes on forever. They see that they are each other's enemy. They know it immediately. I love that their rivalry is born out of a competition for who has seen more films or appreciates movies more.
对于剧中的角色来说，因为我们在9分7秒有两个对手见面，德怀特和安迪。是的。谁也不会中断握手。那次握手持续了很久。他们看到他们是彼此的敌人。他们立刻就知道了。我喜欢他们的竞争源于谁看过的电影更多或更欣赏电影的竞争。
Well, you know, a director. A director has more power. That's, you know, that's Andy's whole thing. Yes. But Dwight has seen 240 films. Over. Over 240. Over 240.
嗯，你知道，导演。导演有更多的权力。那是，你知道，那是安迪的全部。是的。但德怀特看过240部电影。超过。超过240部。超过240部。
Yeah. Yeah, I'd love to see that list. He's got a spreadsheet. Mm. OK, well, we are coming up to one of my very favorite scenes in this whole episode. I have two. I think my second one is maybe one that you like as well. But this one I loved. And if you're relating to Ryan, Jenna, I think I'm relating to Toby. Oh. Because Jim comes over and Toby is excited to see him.
是的。是的，我很想看看那个名单。他有一个电子表格。嗯。好的，好吧，我们快要讲到这一整集中我最喜欢的场景之一了。我有两个。我想我的第二个可能也是你喜欢的。但我喜欢这个。如果你和瑞安有共鸣，珍娜，我想我和托比有共鸣。哦。因为吉姆过来了，托比很兴奋见到他。
And I think Toby just wanted to be cool and he tries to do a fist bump. And then Jim was like, oh, is this what you're doing now? And then Toby's like, oh, just forget it. Just forget it. I'm sorry. I don't know why I did that. And he has like this such self-loathing in this moment
我觉得托比只是想表现得酷一点，他试着做一个碰拳。然后吉姆说，哦，这就是你现在在做的吗？然后托比说，哦，算了。算了。对不起。我不知道我为什么要那样做。他在这一刻有这种自我厌恶
and my heart just breaks for him. But I feel like, I feel like that's what I do. Like whenever I try to be like, I'm gonna be cool. It's like, oh, forget it. That was lame. Oh my God. That was definitely Toby's glitchy up in here moment. Yeah, it got glitchy up in there Toby,
我的心都为他碎了。但我感觉，我觉得这就是我做的。就像每当我试图表现得，我要表现得酷一点。就像，哦，算了。那太逊了。天哪。那绝对是托比在这里的“故障时刻”。是的，托比在那里出故障了，
but it was so like, it felt so honest. Like it felt, I just loved it. Also, I have a little bit of a beef with Jim in this moment. Same. He knows that Toby's trying to be cool. He knows that Toby just wants Jim to like him and he should have just fist bumped him back instead of commenting like, oh, is this what you're doing now? And sort of giving him shade. So Jim, I have issue with you right there. Just fist bump back. Don't comment on the fist bump.
但这太像了，感觉太真实了。就像它感觉，我只是喜欢它。另外，我在这一刻对吉姆有点不满。我也是。他知道托比在试图表现得酷。他知道托比只是想让吉姆喜欢他，他本应该回他一个碰拳，而不是评论说，哦，这就是你现在在做的吗？并给他脸色看。所以吉姆，我在这里对你有意见。只是回一个碰拳。不要评论那个碰拳。
Just do it back. Agree. Agree. I need to bring up something called Shredder Gate. Oh. Angela. OK. Which version of this did you watch for our re-watch?
只是回敬一下。同意。同意。我需要提一下叫“碎纸机门”的事情。哦。安吉拉。好的。你为了我们的重看看了哪个版本？
Did you watch the iTunes version or the Netflix version or the DVD version? I watched the Netflix version and the DVD version because I watched this episode three times. Okay I watched it on iTunes and Netflix. If you watch the iTunes download you will see a whole storyline with Kevin shredding things using a Staples shredder. It has a giant Staples sticker on it, and he talks about what a great shredder it is, and yada yada. If you watch the Netflix version, this storyline is not in there. It is also not on the DVD. So folks who watched the iTunes download like I did, here is what that was about.
你看了iTunes版本还是Netflix版本还是DVD版本？我看了Netflix版本和DVD版本，因为我看了这一集三次。好的，我在iTunes和Netflix上看了。如果你看iTunes下载版，你会看到一个完整的故事情节，凯文用史泰博碎纸机粉碎东西。上面有一个巨大的史泰博贴纸，他谈论这是一个多么好的碎纸机，等等等等。如果你看Netflix版本，这个故事情节不在里面。它也不在DVD上。所以像我一样看iTunes下载版的粉丝们，这就是关于什么的。
This was an embedded advertisement for this staple shredder, which actually existed at the time and was launching, and they paid the show to feature it on the show by one of our characters. They picked Kevin. Something that people should know, like if a show gets money to make a character drink a Coke versus a Pepsi, the actor does not get any coin for that. No, no, no. But also, people noted Staples is Dunder Mifflin's main competitor.
这是一个嵌入式广告，针对这个史泰博碎纸机，它在当时确实存在并且正在推出，他们付钱给节目，让我们的角色在节目中展示它。他们选择了凯文。人们应该知道的一件事，比如如果一个节目得到钱让一个角色喝可乐而不是百事可乐，演员是不会从中得到任何钱的。不，不，不。但人们也注意到，史泰博是邓德·米夫林的主要竞争对手。
Yeah. So it was especially strange. I mean, it's the staples, theoretically, is the whole reason this merger's happening, because that's how they lost Josh Porter. Yes. So it was an odd thing. It was odd.
是的。所以这特别奇怪。我是说，这是史泰博，理论上，是这次合并发生的全部原因，因为那是他们失去乔什·波特的方式。是的。所以这是一件奇怪的事情。这很奇怪。
OK, Angela, so now Michael is ready. Yeah. He's making everyone go in the conference room. Yeah, he has a gigantic performance, Jenna. That's coming up. He has named this the official merger day all-family welcome breakfast. He's put out some food, but only the guests are allowed to eat and drink. So you see the food though?
好的，安吉拉，所以现在迈克尔准备好了。是的。他让每个人都去会议室。是的。他有一个巨大的表演，珍娜。那就要来了。他把这命名为官方合并日全家欢迎早餐。他放了一些食物，但只有客人才被允许吃喝。你看到食物了吗？
It looked like little pieces of toast and salmon. I didn't see anything else in champagne. Yeah. I mean, Pam carried two fake grocery bags into the office, and this is what was in it? I feel like this is on Pam. Is this all Michael gave her money for, or did Pam just do a horrible job of shopping?
看起来像是一小块吐司和三文鱼。我没看到其他东西和香槟。是的。我是说，帕姆带了两个假杂货袋进办公室，这就是里面的东西？我觉得这是帕姆的责任。这是迈克尔给她钱买的所有东西，还是帕姆只是购物做得太糟糕了？
Also, was Angela Martin like, I did the gift bags. I'm out. I'm out. I'm out. I have to say, I don't think Michael used the party planning committee at all here. I feel like Michael put together those gift bags. I don't know. I think the reason this buffet is sad is because the PPC was
另外，安吉拉·马丁是不是说，我做了礼品袋。我退出了。我退出了。我退出了。我必须说，我不认为迈克尔在这里使用了派对策划委员会。我觉得迈克尔组装了那些礼品袋。我不知道。我认为这个自助餐很悲惨的原因是PPC
not involved. I think if you only have two items, it can't be a buffet. I think it's got to be. Well, you're the buffet expert. I'm the buffet expert. I think it's like be. Well, you're the buffet expert, so. I'm the buffet expert. I think it's like three items or more. Also, I love that on their very first day, he is going to insult them all and then also give them champagne.
没有参与。我觉得如果你只有两样东西，它就不可能是自助餐。我觉得它必须是。嗯，你是自助餐专家。我是自助餐专家。我觉得它就像是。嗯，你是自助餐专家，所以。我是自助餐专家。我觉得它就像是三样或更多东西。另外，我喜欢在他们第一天的时候，他要侮辱他们所有人，然后还给他们香槟。
He's like, Michael, Michael would be fired. Michael should already be fired. For sure. For sure. For sure. Also, at 12 minutes, 36 seconds, I see Mindy break. Oh, you do? Yeah. Yeah. So after Michael tells Kelly to consider the salmon to be poisoned beef, Mindy starts to break and puts her hand up to her face as she walks away.
他就像，迈克尔，迈克尔会被解雇的。迈克尔应该已经被解雇了。当然。当然。当然。另外，在12分36秒，我看到明迪笑场了。哦，你看到了？是的。是的。所以迈克尔告诉凯莉把三文鱼当作有毒的牛肉后，明迪开始笑场，并在走开时把手放在脸上。
Oh, I have to go back and look for that. So, Anne, we asked Ken Whittingham, our director, how did he fit everyone in the conference room? I mean, Jenna, we could barely fit in it before five new people. And remember, also in the room with us are two camera operators, two boom operators, and usually a first AD. So there were also additional crew members.
哦，我得回去看看那个。所以，安，我们问了我们的导演肯·惠廷汉姆，他是怎么把每个人都塞进会议室的？我是说，珍娜，我们在五个新人进来之前都很难塞进去。而且记住，和我们在一起的还有两名摄像师、两名吊杆操作员，通常还有一名第一助理导演。所以还有额外的剧组成员。
Should we play the clip? Yeah. To see what Ken said about getting us all in there? Yeah. It was very challenging staging and shooting the conference room scenes. I wanted to create a us and them kind of situation, so I put each branch on opposite sides.
我们要播放片段吗？是的。看看肯是怎么说把我们都塞进去的？是的。布置和拍摄会议室场景非常有挑战性。我想创造一种“我们”和“他们”的情况，所以我把每个分部放在对立面。
However, in the first conference room scene, Karen was the only person from Stanford that I put on the Scranton side. I remember Rashida asking scene, Karen was the only person from Stanford that I put on the Scranton side. I remember Rashida asking me why she was the only person on that side, and I told her the reason being is to put her and Pam and Jim in the same shot to capture all of their reactions
然而，在第一个会议室场景中，凯伦是我唯一一个放在斯克兰顿一侧的斯坦福人。我记得拉什达问我为什么她是那一侧唯一的人，我告诉她原因是把她和帕姆和吉姆放在同一个镜头里，以捕捉他们所有的反应
when Karen passes Jim a stick of gum to pique Pam's curiosity. Okay. This leads me to wishy-washy Jim and the stick of gum. Why is he wishy-washy if he takes a stick of gum? Listen, are they dating or are they not dating? Because when you bring a girl that you are dating into a new office where you used to work
当凯伦递给吉姆一块口香糖来激起帕姆的好奇心时。好的。这让我想到优柔寡断的吉姆和那块口香糖。如果他拿了一块口香糖，他为什么优柔寡断？听着，他们在约会还是没在约会？因为当你把你正在约会的女孩带到一个你曾经工作过的新办公室时
and then you don't sit next to her in the first group meeting? Wishy-washy. What is that? I feel like I'm watching normal people all over again. Did you watch that show? My God. No. All right. Well, yeah, I don't know what he's doing. I don't know if, you know, here's the thing. I do think he's wishy-washy. I don't know what he's doing. I don't know if, you know, here's the thing. I do think he's wishy-washy. I don't know if I support it in this moment, because for all we knew, like, he went in to sit down and to save her seat, but then Pam sat down,
然后你在第一次小组会议上不坐在她旁边？优柔寡断。那是什么？我觉得我好像又在看《正常人》了。你看过那个节目吗？天哪。不。好吧。嗯，是的，我不知道他在做什么。我不知道，你知道，事情是这样的。我确实认为他优柔寡断。我不知道我是否支持他这一刻，因为据我们所知，就像，他进去坐下并为她留了座位，但后来帕姆坐下了，
and now he's like, oh, crap, what do I do? Maybe he's just a little deer in headlights. Well, then maybe he should have moved back to the back row and sat next to Karen. I don't know. Here is what I'm saying. I'm saying we're going to learn at the end of this episode that they're dating.
现在他就像，哦，该死，我该怎么办？也许他只是有点像惊弓之鸟。好吧，那他本应该回到后排坐在凯伦旁边。我不知道。这就是我要说的。我说我们会在这一集结束时知道他们在约会。
And I don't think he is regarding Karen as a woman he is dating right now. I agree with that. Also, he doesn't even say who he's dating at the end of the episode. That too. He doesn't even own that. So. at the end of the episode. That too. He doesn't even own that.
而且我不认为他现在把凯伦视为他正在约会的女人。我同意这一点。另外，他在这一集结束时甚至没说他在和谁约会。那也是。他甚至都不承认这一点。所以。在这一集结束时。那也是。他甚至都不承认。
So... Wishy-washy Jim. Wishy-washy. I actually got to sit next to Rashida in this scene and it was really fun. She was great and we got to chat in between takes and stuff. So I remember being excited. Oh, well, that's very nice. So Jim's loss was my gain. So there you go,
所以……优柔寡断的吉姆。优柔寡断。我实际上在这一幕中坐在拉什达旁边，这真的很有趣。她很棒，我们在拍摄间隙聊天什么的。所以我记得很兴奋。哦，好吧，那很好。所以吉姆的损失是我的收获。所以就这样，
wishy washy, Jim. There you go, wishy washy, Jim. Should we talk about Lazy Scranton, Angela? I can't wait to talk about it. This made me laugh so hard. And of course, you know, there had already been Lazy Sunday on SNL. So this was like inspired by Lazy Sunday. So this was like inspired by Lazy Sunday. And it made me laugh so hard when we watched it. So many of Michael's bits are based on the bits of Saturday Night Live and or other comedians. He really writes no new material.
优柔寡断的吉姆。就这样，优柔寡断的吉姆。我们应该谈谈《懒惰的斯克兰顿》吗，安吉拉？我迫不及待想谈谈它了。这让我笑得太厉害了。当然，你知道，SNL上已经有《懒惰的星期天》了。所以这就像是受《懒惰的星期天》启发。所以这就像是受《懒惰的星期天》启发。当我们看它时，它让我笑得太厉害了。迈克尔的很多段子都是基于《周六夜现场》或其他喜剧演员的段子。他真的写不出什么新素材。
He thinks he's a world class comedian. I mean, he- Because he just restructures and redos other people's bits. But he truly thinks he's like an amazing comedian. He even called this meeting, which should be just like a new employee orientation meeting, he calls it his gigantic performance. Yes. Yes. Michael reminds me of a cruise director.
他认为自己是世界级的喜剧演员。我是说，他——因为他只是重组和重做别人的段子。但他真的认为自己像个了不起的喜剧演员。他甚至把这次会议，本应该只是像一个新员工入职会议，他称之为他的“巨大表演”。是的。是的。迈克尔让我想起了一个游轮总监。
Oh, gosh. Wait, that's perfect. That's all you need to say. reminds me of a cruise director. Oh gosh. Wait, that's perfect. That's all you need to say. I'm sure there's a story here, but that is the best example. Michael is a cruise ship director. Yeah. What you have to tell me the story, what happened on the cruise ship?
哦，天哪。等等，那太完美了。那就是你需要说的全部。让我想起了一个游轮总监。哦，天哪。等等，那太完美了。那就是你需要说的全部。我相信这里有一个故事，但那是最好的例子。迈克尔是游轮总监。是的。你必须告诉我故事，游轮上发生了什么？
Well, I took a cruise and, uh, our cruise director, like 15 years after Austin Powers had come out, his bit was to dress up like Austin Powers and be like, oh, behave. Oh my gosh. And I remember thinking like, has he been doing this bit for 15 years or where is, we are, I don't know. And then, you know, of course there was some Borat thrown in there. It was like watching Michael Scott live. But I'll tell you what, by the end of the cruise, I don't know, this guy, I was on board.
嗯，我坐了一次游轮，呃，我们的游轮总监，在《王牌大贱谍》上映15年后，他的段子就是打扮成王牌大贱谍，然后说，哦，表现好点。哦，天哪。我记得当时想，他是不是已经表演这个段子15年了，或者我们在哪里，我不知道。然后，你知道，当然还有一些《波拉特》的元素。这就像在看迈克尔·斯科特现场直播。但我告诉你，到游轮结束时，我不知道，这家伙，我被说服了。
Like by the end of the cruise. He was like, yeah, baby, yeah. He was like, I'm in. By the end of the cruise, I was full on doing like a scavenger hunt with my mom and my sister. It was a cruise I took with my mom and sister. It was like, you know, a girls trip. Girls trip, yeah.
就像到游轮结束时。他就像，是的，宝贝，是的。他就像，我加入了。到游轮结束时，我完全在和我妈妈和姐姐玩寻宝游戏。那是我和我妈妈姐姐一起坐的游轮。就像，你知道，女孩之旅。女孩之旅，是的。
And we were with a bunch of other strangers and we were doing this scavenger hunt. And like, my poor sister is gonna be so embarrassed when I tell this story. The thing we had to find was just like a piece of woman's clothing. So my sister took off her bra and like took it out of her shirt and was like waving her hair.
我们和一群其他陌生人在一起，我们在玩这个寻宝游戏。而且，我可怜的姐姐在我讲这个故事时会非常尴尬。我们要找的东西只是一件女性服装。所以我姐姐脱掉了她的胸罩，把它从衬衫里拿出来，像挥舞头发一样挥舞着。
She's like, wait, get off my head. And we were like, oh, behave. Oh my God. It wasn't safe. I love that story, Jenna. And you know what? Having now competed with your family in Family Feud, I know how competitive everyone in your family is.
她就像，等等，从我头上拿开。我们就像，哦，表现好点。哦，天哪。那不安全。我喜欢那个故事，珍娜。你知道吗？现在和你家人一起参加过《家庭问答》，我知道你们家里每个人有多好胜。
I believe that Emily was like, oh, we will win this if I have to take my bra off. We're going to win. She was. She was. And we didn't win, I'll say. Well, sadly. But we gave it our best effort. You sure did.
我相信艾米丽当时想，哦，如果我必须脱掉胸罩，我们就会赢。我们要赢。她是。她是。我得说，我们没赢。嗯，遗憾的是。但我们尽了最大努力。你确实尽力了。
All right, so we asked both Ken and Brent what they remembered about filming Lazy Scranton. And here's what Ken Whittingham had to say. One of my favorite scenes in the episode was creating the Lazy Scranton video, which was inspired from SNL's Lazy Sunday sketch. We kind of went off script and created a bunch of really funny extra scenes to make the video really hard to watch for the Dunder Mifflin employees.
好的，所以我们问了肯和布伦特他们对拍摄《懒惰的斯克兰顿》有什么记忆。这是肯·惠廷汉姆要说的。这一集中我最喜欢的场景之一是创作《懒惰的斯克兰顿》视频，它的灵感来自SNL的《懒惰的星期天》小品。我们有点脱离剧本，创作了一堆非常有趣的额外场景，让视频对邓德·米夫林的员工来说真的很难看下去。
Unfortunately, we couldn't use all of them. Hold up, are you telling me there's extra footage from this? Yeah, there must be. I need an extended cut. I want the extended cut of Lazy Scranton. I know. I know because this was one of those moments where Rain and Steve got to go off on their own
不幸的是，我们不能全部使用它们。等等，你是说这里有额外的镜头？是的，一定有。我需要一个加长版。我想要《懒惰的斯克兰顿》的加长版。我知道。我知道，因为这是雷恩和史蒂夫可以自己发挥的时刻之一
and shoot a bunch of stuff. And we only got to see what the audience sees. We only got to see that final version. Yeah. Oh, Ken, I want those extra scenes. All right, well, we also asked Brent. And here's what Brent remembers about shooting those scenes. What I remember about shooting that lazy Scranton video was just being in awe of Rainn Wilson
并拍摄了一堆东西。我们只能看到观众看到的。我们只能看到最终版本。是的。哦，肯，我想要那些额外的场景。好的，好吧，我们也问了布伦特。这是布伦特关于拍摄那些场景的记忆。我记得拍摄那个《懒惰的斯克兰顿》视频时，只是对雷恩·威尔逊感到敬畏
and Steve Carell as performers. These guys are such serious actors, and between takes, they would be talking about this performance like they were the Royal Shakespeare Company, and then the director would yell, action, and they would suddenly become these cartoon characters bouncing off the walls like Bugs Bunny. And then cut and suddenly they're inside the actress studio for about two minutes and then action and it's Benny Hill. It was so wonderful to watch and it ended up,
和史蒂夫·卡瑞尔作为表演者。这些家伙是如此严肃的演员，在拍摄间隙，他们会谈论这个表演，就像他们是皇家莎士比亚剧团一样，然后导演会大喊，开始，他们会突然变成这些卡通人物，像兔八哥一样在墙上弹来弹去。然后喊停，突然他们又在演员工作室待了两分钟，然后开始，又是本尼·希尔。看这个真是太美妙了，它最终，
I think in a kind of classic little bit of comedy film in the middle of the episode. I wish we would have asked them also about the little clip of Michael doing the Scranton witch project. Yes. Because that's something else they filmed. And I'm sure Steve did a whole bunch of stuff that didn't make it.
我想在这一集的中间变成了一段经典的喜剧电影片段。我希望我们也问过他们关于迈克尔做《斯克兰顿女巫计划》的小片段。是的。因为那是他们拍摄的另一件事。我相信史蒂夫拍了很多没用上的东西。
Well, speaking of stuff that didn't make it, Brent sent us in some insight into something that I saw in the script, which was Michael went on to do a magic show for us after showing us Lazy Scranton, but we'll let Brent tell you about it. What I remember about filming this episode is that we ended up with too much comedy. The premise for Michael Scott was so perfect that he would have these new employees and a new audience to perform for and impress that
嗯，说到没用上的东西，布伦特给我们发来了一些我从剧本里看到的见解，那就是迈克尔在展示完《懒惰的斯克兰顿》后继续为我们表演魔术，但我们会让布伦特告诉你。我记得拍摄这一集时，我们最终有了太多的喜剧。迈克尔·斯科特的设定太完美了，他会有这些新员工和新的观众来表演和打动他们，以至于
we just ended up writing too many comedy bits for him and I remember one that made us laugh so hard we had made a giant deck of cards for Michael Scott and in the conference room he says if you put your heart into your sails you will be a king of hearts and then he has an employee pick a card and it is the king of hearts and he says and if you all put your hearts into your sails then you will all be a king of hearts and he flips his deck of cards over and they're all the king of hearts and then he acts like he's blown their minds when in fact he's just done the worst magic trick ever. It was so funny and we just had no room for it because
我们最终写了太多的喜剧段子给他，我记得有一个让我们笑得太厉害了，我们为迈克尔·斯科特做了一副巨大的扑克牌，在会议室里，他说如果你把心投入到你的帆里，你就会成为红心国王，然后他让一个员工选一张牌，结果是红心国王，他说如果你把心投入到你的帆里，那么你们都会成为红心国王，然后他翻开他的扑克牌，它们全是红心国王，然后他表现得好像他震惊了他们，事实上他只是做了有史以来最糟糕的魔术。这太搞笑了，我们根本没有空间放它，因为
the episode was so packed with good stuff. SONIA ANGELA Angela, I remember shooting that. I remember the giant deck of cards. KATE Yeah, and how he fanned them all out. Well, it's in the deleted scenes. SONIA ANGELA Oh, it is? We can watch that. Oh, good.
这一集塞满了太多的好东西。索尼娅·安吉拉·安吉拉，我记得拍摄那个。我记得那副巨大的扑克牌。凯特·是的，还有他怎么把它们全部扇开。嗯，它在删除的场景里。索尼娅·安吉拉·哦，是吗？我们可以看那个。哦，太好了。
KATE Yes. So if you have the DVDs, that one made it. SONIA ANGELA I remember Steve's handling of the prop of the cards and the Kings of Hearts and how he did just like the worst magician hand work with the cards. I just remember trying so hard not to laugh. It was so hard to not laugh. All right, lady, that kind of sums up the first conference room meeting. Oh, there's going to be another one, but should we take a break and then we'll come back? Yeah, let's take a break and come back
凯特·是的。所以如果你有DVD，那个保留了。索尼娅·安吉拉·我记得史蒂夫处理扑克牌道具的方式，以及红心国王，以及他怎么用扑克牌做了最糟糕的魔术师手法。我只记得努力不笑。真的很难不笑。好的，女士，这总结了第一次会议室会议。哦，还会有另一次，但我们应该休息一下，然后再回来吗？是的，让我们休息一下再回来
because Andy continues to try to win over everybody. We'll talk about that when we come back. ["The Daily Show"] ["The Daily Show"] No frills, delivers. Get groceries delivered to your door from No Frills delivers. Get groceries delivered to your door from No Frills with PC Express. Shop online and get $15 in PC Optimum Points on your first five orders. Shop now at nofrills.ca.
因为安迪继续试图赢得每个人的好感。我们回来后再谈那个。["每日秀"] ["每日秀"] 没有多余的装饰，送货上门。从No Frills获得杂货送到你家，没有多余的装饰，送货上门。从No Frills获得杂货送到你家，使用PC Express。在线购物，前五笔订单可获得15美元的PC Optimum积分。现在就在nofrills.ca购物。
All right, so we are back and at 15 minutes, Andy is hitting on Angela. Is that what's happening? Yeah. He has put a cat dressed as a cowboy as his screensaver. And he compliments your smile. What smile? Look at my face. I remember doing this scene and I remember Ken Whittingham
好的，我们回来了，在15分钟时，安迪在勾搭安吉拉。这是在发生什么吗？是的。他把一只打扮成牛仔的猫作为他的屏幕保护程序。他称赞你的微笑。什么微笑？看看我的脸。我记得做这个场景，我记得肯·惠廷汉姆
and Brent Forster and I just brainstorming a little bit. How big would my actual smile be? You know what I mean? Sure, it wouldn't be just like, it couldn't be a smirk. It couldn't be a full smile. It sort of was like this pursed lips, barely reacting, but slightly amused. So we did a few takes of like me sort of like trying to not smile, but seem like I'm somewhat happy.
和布伦特·福斯特和我只是进行了一点头脑风暴。我实际的微笑会有多大？你知道我的意思吗？当然，它不会只是像，它不可能是假笑。它不可能是全笑。它有点像这种抿嘴，几乎没有反应，但有点被逗乐了。所以我们拍了几次，就像我试图不笑，但看起来我有点高兴。
And that like is something that I laughed thinking about because I remember Ken and Brent both being like, okay, maybe even less of a smile or okay, maybe you've got to do something. Like we were like trying to dial it and find it. Well, I love where it landed. I think it's perfect. And it is probably more smiling than we've ever seen from Angela Martin.
而那是我想到时会笑的事情，因为我记得肯和布伦特都说，好的，也许微笑再少一点，或者好的，也许你得做点什么。就像我们试图调整并找到它。嗯，我喜欢它最终的样子。我觉得它很完美。而且这可能比我们从安吉拉·马丁那里看到的微笑要多。
So. Well, I think the biggest smile my character has had is when she realizes that Dwight gave her a key. Yes. That's the biggest smile. But this is amused. Yeah. Slightly amused.
所以。嗯，我觉得我的角色最大的微笑是当她意识到德怀特给了她一把钥匙时。是的。那是最大的微笑。但这只是被逗乐了。是的。有点被逗乐了。
Besides your smile, I was very distracted at 15 minutes, 50 seconds with your all-brown outfit. This is a new color for you. You're usually in the gray tones. These are striking moments because, like, Rain almost always wears mustard yellow. But I noticed in a recent episode, he's in green. He's like, but it's monotone.
除了你的微笑，我在15分50秒被你全身棕色的装束分散了注意力。这是你的新颜色。你通常穿灰色调。这些是引人注目的时刻，因为，就像雷恩几乎总是穿芥末黄。但我注意到在最近的一集中，他穿绿色。他就像，但它是单调的。
Like, that's the other thing. Both you and Dwight dress in, like, a monotone. Mm-hmm. Have you noticed? It's like, yes. Yes. Absolutely. I mean, it was a brown skirt, and then I had a brown button sweater over, like, a black
就像，那是另一件事。你和德怀特都穿得像，单调。嗯哼。你注意到了吗？就像，是的。是的。绝对。我是说，那是一条棕色裙子，然后我在外面穿了一件棕色扣子毛衣，就像，一件黑色
shirt. Like, it was so weird. The whole outfit was so bizarre. Yeah. Should we move to the heartbreak and the break room? Oh, lady. Do you know what I titled this scene on my note card? What?
衬衫。太奇怪了。整套衣服都太离谱了。是啊。我们要不要转到心碎和休息室的话题？噢，天哪。你知道我在笔记卡上给这个场景起的标题是什么吗？什么？
Very Hunchy. Oh, yeah. Very Hunchy. Posture. Posture, Jenna. But it's so true, and you know why she's doing it. Okay, Jenna, set up the scene. Jim is getting a water instead of his usual grape soda from the vending machine and Pam comes in
非常驼背。噢，对。非常驼背。姿势。姿势，珍娜。但这太真实了，而且你知道她为什么这么做。好了，珍娜，布置一下场景。吉姆从自动售货机买水，而不是他平时喝的葡萄汽水，然后帕姆进来了
and she is finally, she has him alone, right? So she wants their old banter back and she's like, oh, no grape soda, huh? And he's like, yeah, no, just water. He doesn't meet her there, right? And she's like, oh, you've changed so much. And he's like, oh yeah, I don't know. And then Michael comes in. And Pam tries to give Jim a little like look a little bit
她终于，她让他单独相处了，对吧？所以她想要回他们以前那种打趣的感觉，她说，噢，没喝葡萄汽水啊？他说，是啊，没喝，就喝水。他没有接她的话，对吧？她说，噢，你变了好多。他说，噢，是啊，我不知道。然后迈克尔进来了。帕姆试图给吉姆一个眼神，有点像
like, Oh, my gosh. And Jim does not return. No, he is giving you nothing back. And he says to Michael, you're not interrupting anything, because nothing's happening. It's kind of cold. And he just leaves. And Pam was like, yeah. And then, Jenna, it looked like if you could have crawled inside your sexy sweater that your mom had knitted you,
噢，天哪。而吉姆没有回应。不，他什么都没给你。他对迈克尔说，你没打断什么，因为什么都没发生。这有点冷淡。然后他就走了。帕姆当时就像，是啊。然后，珍娜，看起来如果你能钻进你妈妈给你织的那件性感毛衣里，
you would have. Because you hunch way into yourself. And I was like, oh, Pam, so hunchy. There's a country song here called Heartbreak in the Break Room, Getting Hunty. I was wearing a sexy sweater that my mama gave me. And then I went in the break room and he broke me. So what did I do?
你肯定会钻进去的。因为你缩着身子，驼着背。我当时想，噢，帕姆，太驼背了。这里有一首乡村歌曲叫《休息室里的心碎，变得驼背》。我穿着妈妈给我的性感毛衣。然后我进了休息室，他让我心碎了。所以我做了什么？
I tried to crawl into my sexy sweater. I got my heart break in the break room. Our country music singing is really breathy. It's not like it's not like peppy like country like there's a heartbreak in the break room and I'm gonna tell you why. Oh, good Lord. Okay. Oh, good Lord. Hey, can I put it out there? Anybody want to write Heartbreak in the Break Room? We'll play it. Here are your keywords.
我试着钻进我的性感毛衣。我在休息室里心碎了。我们唱的乡村音乐真的很轻声细语。它不像那种欢快的乡村音乐，就像休息室里有心碎，我会告诉你为什么。噢，天哪。好吧。噢，天哪。嘿，我可以提个建议吗？有人想写《休息室里的心碎》吗？我们会播放它的。这是你们的关键词。
Heartbreak in the Break Room. Very hunchy. Sexy sweater. Mama's sexy sweater. Yeah, mama knit me a sexy sweater for my heartbreak in the break room. Oh, there it is. Mama knit me a sexy sweater, but all it got me was heartbreak in the break room. Oh, there it is. Mama knit me a sexy sweater, but all it got me was heartbreak in the break room.
休息室里的心碎。非常驼背。性感毛衣。妈妈的性感毛衣。是啊，妈妈给我织了一件性感毛衣，为了我在休息室里的心碎。噢，就是这样。妈妈给我织了一件性感毛衣，但它只带给我休息室里的心碎。噢，就是这样。妈妈给我织了一件性感毛衣，但它只带给我休息室里的心碎。
Oh, come on. All right. So now, where do we go from here? I mean, where do we go from here? Hannah is pumping in the bullpen. Creed is leering at her. Creed's so gross. Ryan is like, hey, I'm sorry it's distracting. Angela does not approve. Jenna, you and I both breastfed. We both had pumps. We had to pump at work. But I would not have pumped in a bullpen.
噢，拜托。好吧。那么，我们接下来去哪儿？我是说，我们接下来去哪儿？汉娜在办公区挤奶。克里德在斜眼看她。克里德真恶心。瑞安说，嘿，抱歉这让人分心。安吉拉不赞同。珍娜，你我都喂过母乳。我们都有吸奶器。我们不得不在工作时吸奶。但我不会在办公区吸奶。
No, I wouldn't have pumped in a bullpen. I've pumped in lots of places. I have pumped while driving down the road. While you were driving? While I was driving. I had a day. While you were driving? While I was driving. I had a day where I had to go to a meeting and the traffic in Los Angeles is so bad that I was not gonna make it home in time
不，我不会在办公区吸奶。我在很多地方吸过奶。我甚至在开车时吸过奶。你开车的时候？我开车的时候。有一天，我得去开会，洛杉矶的交通太糟糕了，我没法及时赶回家
to pump and or breastfeed. So I put after my meeting, I got in my car, I hooked up my pump with my hands-free bandana thing. Oh, yeah, you had the hands-free one. And I just pumped as I drove. I also pumped in a restroom at the airport. That was really the grossest experience of my life. This was before airports had nursing lounges.
去吸奶或者喂奶。所以开完会后，我上了车，用我的免提头巾装置接上了吸奶器。噢，对，你有那个免提的。我就一边开车一边吸奶。我还在机场的洗手间里吸过奶。那真是我一生中最恶心的经历。那是在机场有哺乳室之前。
Yeah. I pumped in the coat closet of the Screen Actors Guild Awards. I remember that. And Lady, a couple of years later, I did the same. And I remember you being like, oh, Jenna, I'll show you where to go. Here, here's this coat closet I used several years ago. Yeah.
是啊。我在美国演员工会奖的衣帽间里吸过奶。我记得那个。而且，女士，几年后，我也做了同样的事。我记得你说，噢，珍娜，我带你去个地方。来，这是我几年前用过的衣帽间。是啊。
And I was like, great. You really, you helped me out. So Jenna, now we have basically the Stanford branch and the Scranton branch trying to work all together. And it's bumpy, right? It's like having that new roommate and it is, they're having to sit next to each other. Like Creed is laughing way too loud on the phone.
我说，太棒了。你真的帮了我大忙。所以珍娜，现在我们基本上是斯坦福分部和斯克兰顿分部试图一起工作。这很坎坷，对吧？就像有了个新室友，他们不得不坐在一起。比如克里德在电话里笑得太大声了。
Hannah is pumping in the bullpen, Martin tries to have this moment with Stanley, and then of course there's Karen and Phyllis. We'll get to that. Yes, well we got a fan question about that moment between Martin and Stanley. Kenya Hunt wrote in to say, "'As a Black American, I personally lived
汉娜在办公区挤奶，马丁试图和斯坦利有那种互动，当然还有凯伦和菲利斯。我们稍后会谈到。是的，我们收到一个粉丝关于马丁和斯坦利那一刻的问题。肯尼亚·亨特写道：作为一名美国黑人，我个人非常
"'for the really intimate details about blackness in the show, like Daryl teaching Michael Dinkin-Flicke, for example. Another example is the moment between Martin and Stanley in this episode. Martin tries to give Stanley the black nod, the nod black people give each other as a sign of understanding in mostly white spaces.
喜欢剧中关于黑人身份的那些非常私密的细节，比如达里尔教迈克尔“Dinkin-Flicke”，举个例子。另一个例子是这一集中马丁和斯坦利之间的那一刻。马丁试图给斯坦利一个“黑人点头”，那是黑人在大多是白人的空间里作为理解标志而给对方的点头。
And Stanley rejects him. It is too funny. Who wrote that part or was it improvised? Well, we asked Brent Forrester, our writer about that. And here's what he had to say. That was written into the script, but the performers, Leslie David Baker and the great Wayne Wilderson, who played Martin, They did make it their own and it was directed by Ken Whittingham who I remember thought it was very, very funny. And yeah, that was a collaboration for sure.
而斯坦利拒绝了他。这太搞笑了。是谁写的那部分，还是即兴创作的？好吧，我们问了我们的编剧布伦特·福雷斯特。他是这么说的。那是写在剧本里的，但演员们，莱斯利·大卫·贝克和伟大的韦恩·威尔德森（饰演马丁），他们确实把它变成了自己的东西，而且是由肯·惠廷汉姆执导的，我记得他觉得这非常非常搞笑。是的，那绝对是一次合作。
So glad you liked that. And here's what our director, Ken had to say about that moment. The interaction between Martin and Stanley was written by Brent Forrester and yes, it was scripted. And I laugh out loud every time I watch it. It just really kills me. Some of us know that guy. Okay. So now is one of my favorite scenes in this whole episode. Same. I mean, we didn't even talk about this.
很高兴你喜欢那个。这是我们的导演肯对那一刻的评价。马丁和斯坦利之间的互动是由布伦特·福雷斯特写的，是的，那是剧本里的。我每次看都会大笑出声。它真的让我笑死。我们有些人认识那种人。好吧。现在是这一整集中我最喜欢的场景之一。我也是。我是说，我们甚至还没谈到这个。
And then this morning when we were getting ready to do it, it's we both had this scene down as like, we've got to hear this scene because we love it so much. Karen is sitting at her desk, and she is like, what is that smell? Smells like a funeral home. Smells like a funeral home, she says. Yeah.
今天早上我们准备录制的时候，我们俩都把这个场景记下来，觉得我们一定要聊聊这个场景，因为我们太喜欢它了。凯伦坐在她的办公桌前，她说，那是什么味道？闻起来像殡仪馆。闻起来像殡仪馆，她说。是啊。
We come to find out it's Phyllis's perfume. Phyllis is like, oh, I'll help you find the smell. And then Karen is like, oh, oh, I think I'm allergic to your perfume. And Phyllis has a response that I love so much. This is Phyllis Sass, right, Angela? Such Phyllis Sass, so much so there's part of it I want on a t-shirt.
我们发现那是菲利斯的香水。菲利斯说，噢，我帮你找找那味道。然后凯伦说，噢，噢，我想我对你的香水过敏。菲利斯有一个我非常喜欢的回答。这就是“菲利斯式刻薄”，对吧，安吉拉？太“菲利斯式刻薄”了，以至于我想把其中的一部分印在T恤上。
It's so great. Can we play a clip of it? Yes. Please. Oh, you know, never, never mind. What is it? I think I'm just allergic to your perfume. My perfume? It's just my crazy nose. I, um, used to different smells.
太棒了。我们可以放一段剪辑吗？好的。请。噢，你知道，没，没关系。是什么？我想我只是对你的香水过敏。我的香水？只是我的鼻子太敏感了。我，嗯，习惯了不同的气味。
Bob Vance bought this perfume for me in Metropolitan Orlando. It's made from real pine. Who's Bob Vance? You have a lot to learn about this town, sweetie. Oh, the First Lady of Vance Refrigeration is not pleased. Phyllis is pissed. Yeah. First of all, she insults her perfume, and it's from Metropolitan Orlando. Hello.
鲍勃·万斯在奥兰多大都会区给我买的这款香水。它是用真正的松木制成的。鲍勃·万斯是谁？你对这个镇子了解得还不够多，亲爱的。噢，万斯制冷公司的第一夫人不高兴了。菲利斯生气了。是啊。首先，她侮辱了她的香水，而且那是来自奥兰多大都会区的。你好。
Yeah. It's made with real pine. Angela. And then Karen doesn't know who Bob Vance is? Ugh. Ugh. Oh no. Good luck, Karen.
是啊。它是用真正的松木制成的。安吉拉。然后凯伦不知道鲍勃·万斯是谁？呃。呃。噢，不。祝你好运，凯伦。
Good luck. You really stepped in it, Karen. And Stanley has that amazing talking head where he is like, I don't know who these new people think they are, but I have sat downwind of Phyllis' stinky perfume for years and I have never said a word. Yeah. Oh man, no one's getting along. No one's getting along from the new branch and it's all gonna come to a head.
祝你好运。你真的踩雷了，凯伦。斯坦利有那个精彩的采访镜头，他说，我不知道这些新来的人以为他们是谁，但我坐在菲利斯那臭香水的下风处好几年了，我从来没说过一句话。是啊。噢，天哪，没人能相处。新分部的人没人能相处，这一切都要爆发了。
I love throughout the series the sort of subtle tension that happens from time to time between Phyllis and Stanley, I have to say. Every once in a while, Phyllis gets real annoyed with him. And then now we're getting a peek into what Stanley has endured in that desk clump. Years of this perfume. They're like an old married couple, the two of them. They really are. They have each other's back, but they also like drive each other crazy. But it's a sort of like subtle, quiet anger. They definitely eat dinner in silence. Right?
我喜欢整个系列中菲利斯和斯坦利之间不时出现的微妙紧张感，我必须得说。每隔一段时间，菲利斯就会对他在意得要命。现在我们得以一窥斯坦利在那个办公桌区域忍受了什么。多年的这种香水。他们俩就像一对老夫老妻。他们真的是。他们互相支持，但也互相折磨。但这是一种微妙、安静的愤怒。他们绝对是沉默着吃晚饭的。对吧？
They're that couple in the restaurant and they haven't said a word for 30 minutes. It's because they've been together so long. They've said everything they need to say. Exactly. Exactly. Oh, I love it so much. Angela, I have to point something out here. This is a tangent, but it's short. You know, we're talking about how this is Phyllis Sass.
他们就是餐馆里那种30分钟没说一句话的夫妻。那是因为他们在一起太久了。他们该说的话都说完了。没错。没错。噢，我太喜欢了。安吉拉，我必须指出一点。这是一个题外话，但很短。你知道，我们谈论这是“菲利斯式刻薄”。
You really coined the Sass. A fan sent in that on one of our episodes in the podcast notes, it says that our episodes in the podcast notes, it says that our guest on the episode is Michael Sass. What? Yes. Like on the Apple download site, it says like our guests are, and then it lists the guests
你真的创造了这个词。一位粉丝发来消息说，在我们播客笔记的一集里，它说我们那一集的嘉宾是迈克尔·萨斯（Michael Sass）。什么？是的。就像在苹果下载网站上，它说我们的嘉宾是，然后列出了嘉宾
and one of the guests is Michael Sass. There's no photo for him though. That is hilarious. Whatever the algorithm is that like listens to your podcast and then picks out guest stars to highlight, somehow this computer program believes that there's someone on our podcast named Michael Sass. Because we've said Sass so many times, it's now like the thing the computer picks up on. Yeah, Sass is one of our guest stars.
其中一位嘉宾是迈克尔·萨斯。不过没有他的照片。这太搞笑了。无论是什么算法在听你们的播客然后挑选嘉宾来突出显示，这个电脑程序不知何故认为我们的播客里有一个叫迈克尔·萨斯的人。因为我们说了太多次“萨斯”（Sass），它现在成了电脑捕捉到的东西。是啊，萨斯是我们的一位嘉宾。
All right, so guys, it's hard to believe, but Michael didn't feel like one conference room meeting was enough. He makes everyone go inside for what he's now calling the integration celebration. Well, he's really noticed that no one's getting along, and he's worried about it. And so he says, you know, I mean,
好了，伙计们，很难相信，但迈克尔觉得一次会议室会议还不够。他让每个人都进去参加他现在所说的“融合庆典”。好吧，他真的注意到没人能相处，他很担心。所以他说，你知道，我的意思是，
a great show can make people forget about their differences. You got to give them another great show, everybody. Yeah. So what he decides to do is reenact another Saturday Night Live bit. This time Night at the Roxbury. And this is what Michael thinks. This is this is the way to bring everyone together. Yeah, to imitate these idiots at the nightclub. But his boombox doesn't work. Ugh.
一场精彩的表演能让人忘记分歧。你们得再给他们一场精彩的表演，各位。是啊。所以他决定重演另一个《周六夜现场》的片段。这次是《舞翻天》（Night at the Roxbury）。这就是迈克尔的想法。这是让大家团结起来的方法。是啊，模仿夜店里的这些白痴。但他的音箱坏了。呃。
So Andy comes to the rescue and he sings for him. Andy starts going, ping pong, ping pong, ping pong, ping pong, ping pong, ping pong, ping pong, ping pong, ping pong, he starts doing that. Well, none of us knew what that was going to sound like, really, right? Yeah, it was just in the script that he would provide the music.
所以安迪来救场了，他为他唱歌。安迪开始唱，乒乓，乒乓，乒乓，乒乓，乒乓，乒乓，乒乓，乒乓，乒乓，他开始那样做。好吧，我们谁都不知道那听起来会是什么样，真的，对吧？是啊，剧本里只写了他会提供音乐。
Right? And so I don't think we were really prepared for Ed Helms as Andy to go full out. And we lost it. And that's when I did my snort laugh because we're all in this little room and it's totally quiet. And then with full commitment, Ed is like, peep-a-peep-a-peep-a-peep. It was like so crazy. Sorry, I dropped my pencil. I was like, ah, it was crazy. That was amazing. I'll never forget that.
对吧？所以我认为我们真的没准备好艾德·赫尔姆斯饰演的安迪会全力以赴。我们笑疯了。那就是我发出那种猪叫笑声的时候，因为我们都在这个小房间里，完全安静。然后艾德全情投入地唱着，peep-a-peep-a-peep-a-peep。太疯狂了。抱歉，我铅笔掉了。我当时想，啊，太疯狂了。那太棒了。我永远不会忘记那个。
And also remember, Ed was new to us. So we were like, oh, oh, he showed up in full uniform ready to play today. Yeah, we didn't know what was coming. Yeah. That's so good. Ed made us laugh so hard. So next, Michael asks all of the new employees to sit up on the conference table.
还要记住，艾德对我们来说是新人。所以我们当时想，噢，噢，他今天全副武装准备好表演了。是啊，我们不知道接下来会发生什么。是啊。太棒了。艾德让我们笑得太厉害了。所以接下来，迈克尔要求所有新员工坐在会议桌上。
This is to illustrate that the older employees are not above them. I have some fun trivia from Dunderpedia about this moment. Okay, Dunderpedia, what do you got? Dunderpedia notes that in the British version, they have an episode called Motivation, and the manager David Brent says he would never make his employees stand on a table because it's against health and safety regulations.
这是为了说明老员工并不比他们高人一等。我从Dunderpedia那里得到了一些关于这一刻的有趣琐事。好的，Dunderpedia，你有什么？Dunderpedia指出，在英国版中，他们有一集叫《动力》，经理大卫·布伦特说他永远不会让员工站在桌子上，因为这违反了健康和安全规定。
Kind of fun little thing. Fun little thing. I guess Michael never read the health and safety memo ever. Oh, clearly. This is Toby's whole life is having to try to catch Michael up on every regulation. Yeah. So there's one person who's not on the table. It's Tony. And Michael says, Tony, let's who's not on the table. It's Tony.
挺有趣的小事。有趣的小事。我猜迈克尔从来没读过健康和安全备忘录。噢，显然。托比的整个人生就是试图让迈克尔跟上每一项规定。是啊。所以有一个人没在桌子上。是托尼。迈克尔说，托尼，让我们谁没在桌子上。是托尼。
And Michael says, Tony, let's get you up on the table. Right? And Tony is like, yeah, I can't. I can't get on the table. And Michael's like, no, yes, you can. He's thinking there's like, right, like he's like giving him a pep talk to get on the table. And then Tony is like, no, I like I physically can't get on the table. But then Tony is like, no, I physically can't get on the table.
迈克尔说，托尼，让你上桌子。对吧？托尼说，是啊，我不能。我不能上桌子。迈克尔说，不，是的，你可以。他以为有什么，对吧，就像他在给他打气让他上桌子。然后托尼说，不，我像我身体上不能上桌子。但托尼又说，不，我身体上不能上桌子。
But Michael will not let it go. He's like, we'll help you. We will physically help you get on the table. Yeah, and then he gets Dwight involved. And then it's just, it's really cringy. And I remember, like even when we were there, being like, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god. And then Tony is like, stop it, I'm done.
但迈克尔不肯罢休。他说，我们会帮你的。我们会身体力行地帮你上桌子。是啊，然后他让德怀特参与进来。然后，这真的很尴尬。我记得，即使我们在现场时，也觉得，噢天哪，噢天哪，噢天哪。然后托尼说，停下，我受够了。
I am done. Yes, and he says, I can't work here. I can't work here. And of course Michael is like, oh my God, is it Toby? And Tony's like, no, Toby was actually very kind and helpful, it is you. It is your management style. But Tony is being nicer about it than I am. He's like, no, Michael, it's your management style.
我受够了。是的，他说，我不能在这里工作。我不能在这里工作。当然迈克尔说，噢天哪，是因为托比吗？托尼说，不，托比其实非常友善和乐于助人，是你。是你的管理风格。但托尼比我更客气。他说，不，迈克尔，是你的管理风格。
And Michael cannot believe it. He cannot believe that there would be someone who doesn't think he's an awesome manager. Michael cannot hold up the mirror to see himself. He just can't. And throughout the course of this day, he's been disrespectful to all the new employees. And Tony has had it.
迈克尔简直不敢相信。他不敢相信会有人认为他不是个出色的经理。迈克尔无法照镜子审视自己。他就是做不到。在这一天里，他对所有新员工都很不尊重。托尼受够了。
He's not going to work in this environment anymore. But of course, Michael gets hurt and embarrassed and turns it around and says, you know what? You're fired. I'm firing you. To Dwight's delight, Dwight is like, that's what I said. I said we should fire him. So Dwight takes it as a win, and Tony is just like, I can't, I can't even.
他再也不会在这种环境下工作了。但当然，迈克尔感到受伤和尴尬，于是反过来指责说，你知道吗？你被解雇了。我解雇你。德怀特很高兴，德怀特说，我就是这么说的。我说我们应该解雇他。所以德怀特把它当作一场胜利，而托尼只是觉得，我不能，我甚至无法。
Yeah, and you start to see that Hannah is like, yeah, he's got the right idea, right? Yes. And it's unraveling. All of this is unraveling, and Michael is starting to spiral. Now, we had a few fan catches and questions about this scene. First, I'm gonna give you this fan catch from Luke Jensen.
是啊，你开始看到汉娜觉得，是啊，他有道理，对吧？是的。一切都在瓦解。所有这一切都在瓦解，迈克尔开始失控。现在，我们收到了一些粉丝关于这个场景的捕捉和问题。首先，我要给你这个来自卢克·詹森的粉丝捕捉。
He says, I noticed a potentially huge mistake in season three, episode eight, the merger. The episode depicts the entire merger day and Tony Gardner gets fired, right? Yeah. But then in the Threat Level Midnight movie, Tony Gardner is playing the piano. How is it that Tony Gardner ended up in this movie of Threat Level Midnight? There's no way that Michael filmed Threat Level Midnight on this one merger day.
他说，我注意到第三季第八集《合并》中一个潜在的巨大错误。这一集描绘了整个合并日，托尼·加德纳被解雇了，对吧？是啊。但后来在《午夜威胁》（Threat Level Midnight）电影中，托尼·加德纳在弹钢琴。托尼·加德纳怎么会出现在这部《午夜威胁》电影里？迈克尔不可能在这一天合并日里拍完《午夜威胁》。
Right? That is a great catch. Here's the thing. BJ Novak gave an interview about this. Oh. BJ said that the writers thought that it would be very funny for Tony Gardner to have a cameo in Threat Level Midnight. And they have this whole weird backstory as to why he appears in Threat Level Midnight. They think that Michael had this realization, and he called up Tony Gardner and apologized profusely for the way he treated him, and then said, I would like to offer you a role in my movie.
对吧？那是个很棒的捕捉。事情是这样的。BJ·诺瓦克接受过关于这个的采访。噢。BJ说编剧们认为让托尼·加德纳在《午夜威胁》中客串会非常有趣。他们有一整套奇怪的背景故事来解释他为什么出现在《午夜威胁》中。他们认为迈克尔有了这个领悟，他打电话给托尼·加德纳，为他对待他的方式深表歉意，然后说，我想在我的电影里给你一个角色。
And Tony was like... BJ, in the interview, says, like, in his mind, Tony was like either like, well, I don't know, I have in his mind, Tony was like, either like, well, I don't know, I have nothing else better to do. Like maybe he's bored. He's like, maybe he wanted to be in a movie. Maybe he was aspiring actor on the side. Maybe he's a cinephile and I was like, yeah, I'd like to be in a movie.
托尼当时……BJ在采访中说，在他心里，托尼当时想的是，嗯，我不知道，我有什么更好的事做吗？就像也许他很无聊。他说，也许他想演电影。也许他是个业余演员。也许他是个影迷，然后我想，是啊，我想演电影。
Why not? I love movies. But that this was, this was like a choice that they would have this person that Michael wronged in an earlier episode have this cameo in threat level midnight. I like it. I like it. So there you go. I want Michael to have growth. I want him to learn and evolve.
为什么不呢？我喜欢电影。但这是一种选择，他们会让这个在早期剧集中被迈克尔冤枉的人在《午夜威胁》中客串。我喜欢。我喜欢。所以就是这样。我希望迈克尔能成长。我希望他能学习和进化。
Now here's another fan question from this moment. At 22 minutes 56 seconds, Tim Althaus, Sydney Pauls, Ben Pavey, Grace Bromley, and Declan Jensen all want to know who is the man wearing business attire who is standing next to Andy in the conference room when Michael fires Tony. Did you notice it, Ange? Oh, I noticed it. I noticed it and then I saw all the questions pouring in about it. I noticed it, and then I saw all the questions pouring in about it. Yeah. Philip Centani.
现在这是这一刻的另一个粉丝问题。在22分56秒，蒂姆·奥尔特豪斯、悉尼·保尔斯、本·帕维、格蕾丝·布罗姆利和德克兰·詹森都想知道，当迈克尔解雇托尼时，站在会议室安迪旁边那个穿着商务装的男人是谁？你注意到了吗，安吉？噢，我注意到了。我注意到了，然后我看到所有关于它的问题涌进来。我注意到了，然后我看到所有关于它的问题涌进来。是啊。菲利普·森塔尼。
That's who that is, guys. He was one of our male stand-ins for the actors. It was Philip and Stephen Salks were our two male stand-ins. And you will probably spot Stephen in some future episodes in some scenes. And his wife, Lori, has already been in one. That's who that was. Good catch.
那就是那个人，伙计们。他是我们演员的男性替身之一。那是菲利普和斯蒂芬·索尔克斯，我们的两个男性替身。你可能会在未来的剧集和场景中发现斯蒂芬。他的妻子洛里已经出现过一次了。那就是那个人。捕捉得好。
Good catch, guys. Very good catch. So, Michael's really bummed. He says that today was supposed to be a love union, but it's more like when his mom moved in with Jeff. And now his job is to fix it. He's got to fix it, you guys. And how does he decide to fix it? He goes into the parking lot and lets the air out of everyone's tire.
捕捉得好，伙计们。非常好。所以，迈克尔真的很沮丧。他说今天本该是一个爱的结合，但更像是他妈妈搬去和杰夫住的时候。现在他的工作是修复它。他必须修复它，伙计们。他决定怎么修复它？他走到停车场，把每个人的轮胎气都放了。
And he's like, oh my god, we got punked. You know, they got us good, come see. Like he thinks this is going to bring everyone together. Yeah, that's right. But Angela, everyone's tires except Michael's. Yes, and he got a hate note that says that you guys suck. It's from Vance Refrigeration and that they suck. Because Vance Refrigeration would suddenly,
他说，噢天哪，我们被整了。你知道，他们整得我们很惨，来看看。就像他认为这会让大家团结起来。是啊，没错。但安吉拉，除了迈克尔的，所有人的轮胎。是的，他收到一张仇恨纸条，说你们烂透了。那是来自万斯制冷公司的，说他们烂透了。因为万斯制冷公司会突然，
for no reason, decide to hate on Dunder Mifflin. It makes so much sense. But they would spare Michael's car. Well, they saved the worst for him with the hate note, according to Michael. Yeah. And everyone's like, oh, come on. They totally know he's full of crap.
无缘无故地决定讨厌邓德·米夫林。这太合理了。但他们会放过迈克尔的车。好吧，根据迈克尔的说法，他们把最糟糕的留给了他，那张仇恨纸条。是啊。每个人都觉得，噢，拜托。他们完全知道他在胡扯。
Now they're really annoyed. But I guess Michael, in some way, Jenna, he was kind of like on the mark because what brings people together more than a common enemy? Yes, the enemy though is Michael. Yeah. Because then you have that great scene of everybody standing around. Karen and Phyllis, they have a nice moment because Phyllis says, oh, Bob has an air pump and they're going to put
现在他们真的很恼火。但我猜迈克尔，在某种程度上，珍娜，他有点说对了，因为有什么比共同的敌人更能让人们团结起来呢？是的，敌人却是迈克尔。是啊。因为然后你就有那个精彩的场景，每个人都站在那里。凯伦和菲利斯，她们有一个美好的时刻，因为菲利斯说，噢，鲍勃有一个充气泵，他们会把
air in all of our tires so we can get home. And then Karen is like, oh, you mean Bob Vance from Vance Refrigeration? And Phyllis is like, yeah, she's got it. Yeah, everyone is starting to bond. I can't breeze past the moment though where Pam clocks. Karen scratching Jim's back. Well, scratchy scratchy. This is what I'm saying. They're clearly dating.
我们所有轮胎都充上气，这样我们就能回家了。然后凯伦说，噢，你是说万斯制冷公司的鲍勃·万斯？菲利斯说，是啊，她明白了。是啊，每个人都开始建立联系了。但我不能略过帕姆注意到凯伦抓挠吉姆背部的那一刻。嗯，抓啊抓。这就是我说的。他们显然在约会。
Why? Why does Jim come into the new office and not tell the new woman that he's dating, that he's kissed the receptionist, and why doesn't he give Pam a heads up? Wishy washy, Jim. Kiss the receptionist? How about the fact that he told her, I love you?
为什么？为什么吉姆来到新办公室，不告诉那个新女人他在约会，他吻过前台，为什么他不给帕姆提个醒？优柔寡断的吉姆。吻过前台？他告诉她“我爱你”这件事怎么说？
I know. We've discussed this. We've talked about this. This is our beef with Jim. I know. It's our beef with Jim. Well, now Michael's in trouble, though. Michael's in trouble because Jan finds out that he fired Tony when Tony was quitting. And now they have to pay Tony a big severance package. Yeah, exactly. And Michael's in trouble with Jan. And he tries to blame Dwight.
我知道。我们讨论过这个。我们谈过这个。这就是我们对吉姆的不满。我知道。这是我们对吉姆的不满。好吧，现在迈克尔有麻烦了，因为简发现他在托尼辞职时解雇了他。现在他们必须付给托尼一大笔遣散费。是啊，没错。迈克尔惹简生气了。他试图责怪德怀特。
He's like, well, this was the advice of my number two. And Jan is like, he's not your number two. Jim is your number two. So then Michael calls Jim, Dwight, and Andy into his office and makes it seem like he's chosen Jim to be his number two, even though we know from this phone call it was mandated by Jan.
他说，嗯，这是我的二把手的建议。简说，他不是你的二把手。吉姆才是你的二把手。所以迈克尔把吉姆、德怀特和安迪叫进办公室，让它看起来像是他选择了吉姆作为他的二把手，尽管我们从这个电话里知道这是简强制要求的。
And now Dwight and Andy wanna know who's your number three. It's so funny to me that they so quickly gloss over that neither one of them is number two. They're just interested in like, well, now who's number three? Yeah. I mean, I would imagine that Dwight would have been mortified that Jim got number two over him. But I guess now he's just more worried about Andy getting three and having Jim and Andy over him.
现在德怀特和安迪想知道谁是你的三把手。我觉得很有趣的是，他们这么快就掩盖了他们俩都不是二把手的事实。他们只是对“好吧，那谁是三把手？”感兴趣。是啊。我是说，我想德怀特会因为吉姆当上二把手而感到羞愧。但我猜现在他更担心安迪当上三把手，让吉姆和安迪都压在他头上。
So everyone's leaving. This insane day is done. And Karen calls Jim. He's in his car, invites him out for a drink. Yeah. And Jim's like, wait, can I call you right back? Because he sees Pam. And Jenna, is this this moment where Jim is going to try to be real with her?
所以每个人都要走了。这疯狂的一天结束了。凯伦给吉姆打电话。他在车里，邀请他出去喝一杯。是啊。吉姆说，等等，我能马上回你电话吗？因为他看到了帕姆。珍娜，这是吉姆试图对她坦诚的时刻吗？
Maybe, but it's too little too late for Pam. She's really stung. She's embarrassed. She would have liked this information. I mean, she really would have behaved differently in this day had she known. And so she kind of cuts him off. You know, he tries to say, oh, hey, I'm sorry, I think things were a little awkward today. And she's like, yep, no, I don't know.
也许吧，但对帕姆来说太晚了。她真的很受伤。她很尴尬。她本希望得到这个信息。我是说，如果她早知道，她今天表现得会完全不同。所以她有点打断了他。你知道，他试图说，噢，嘿，抱歉，我觉得今天有点尴尬。她说，是啊，没，我不知道。
See, it was fine. I don't know what you're talking about. And he's like, yeah, well, you know, I'm dating someone. And she's like, yeah, well, you can do what you want, because we're friends. And we'll always be friends. Yeah. Yeah, yeah, she was she was kind of cold in that moment and kind of shut him down. But you know, I see both sides. I see her being hurt. But I also see him as being like, you're
看，没关系。我不知道你在说什么。他说，是啊，嗯，你知道，我在和某人约会。她说，是啊，嗯，你想做什么就做什么，因为我们是朋友。我们永远是朋友。是啊。是啊，是啊，她在那一刻有点冷淡，有点拒绝了他。但你知道，我两边都理解。我理解她受伤了。但我同时也理解他觉得，你
not the person I share with anymore. So I don't need to tell you I'm dating anyone. It's none of your business. Oh, yeah. I mean, you know? Yeah. Well, Brent Forrester sent us an audio clip about this Jim Pam storyline that runs through this episode,
不再是我分享心事的人了。所以我不需要告诉你我在和谁约会。这不关你的事。噢，是啊。我是说，你知道？是啊。好吧，布伦特·福雷斯特给我们发了一段关于吉姆和帕姆这条贯穿本集故事线的音频剪辑，
and it's going to seem like I paid him to say this stuff. I just wanna preface this clip by saying I did not know he was going to send this in. Oh, let me tell you, there's going to be like balloons and confetti going off when he mentions Jenna's name. He really, really, really admired your performance. Yes. So everyone, this is not a paid endorsement. Go ahead. If you look at the structure of this episode, you can see it was kind of designed to be a classic
看起来好像是我付钱让他说这些话的。我只想在播放这段剪辑前声明，我不知道他会发这个过来。噢，让我告诉你，当他提到珍娜的名字时，会有气球和彩带飘落。他真的，真的，真的非常钦佩你的表演。是的。所以各位，这不是付费代言。开始吧。如果你看这一集的结构，你可以看出它被设计成经典的
office episode. It's got that big A-story performance piece for Steve Carell where Michael Scott has twice the audience, twice the family to perform for and we knew that Steve was just going to kill it in these big performance conference room scenes. We also knew that we had this clash of two comedy characters who had never been in any scenes before. That was Andy Bernard and Dwight Schrute and sure enough that two-hander is just so funny to watch those guys performing together for the first time.
《办公室》剧集。它有史蒂夫·卡瑞尔那段精彩的A故事表演，迈克尔·斯科特有两倍的观众，两倍的家庭要表演，我们知道史蒂夫在这些大型会议室表演场景中绝对会大放异彩。我们也知道我们有这两个从未在任何场景中出现过的喜剧角色之间的冲突。那是安迪·伯纳德和德怀特·舒特，果然，那段双人戏看着他们俩第一次一起表演真是太搞笑了。
But what really distinguishes this episode is the Jim and Pam story, where once again, we relied for the emotion of the episode on Jim and Pam. And look at the tremendous performance that Jenna Fisher delivers here. She does so much with so little right from the start, where she says, it'll be nice to see my friend again and you know that what she means is I can't believe Jim and I can get together for the first time.
但真正让这一集与众不同的是吉姆和帕姆的故事，我们再次依靠吉姆和帕姆来支撑这一集的感情。看看珍娜·费舍在这里带来的精彩表演。她用那么少的台词做了那么多，从一开始她说，“能再见到我的朋友真好”，你知道她的意思是“我不敢相信吉姆和我能第一次聚在一起”。
And then watch how she discovers that Jim is dating Karen Filippelli. It's just done in little looks where she notices a piece of gum pass between them. Oh, it kills me, man. It's the greatest performance and it's part of this tremendous, ongoing performance that Jenna Fischer did as Pam Beasley. One of the great performances ever captured on TV, in my opinion. Yeah, it really is. It really is one of the greatest performances ever captured on TV. I wrote that out for him and I felt like he delivered it perfectly. Thank you, Brent. No, no.
然后看她是如何发现吉姆在和凯伦·菲利佩利约会。这只是通过小小的眼神完成的，她注意到他们之间传递的一块口香糖。噢，它让我心碎，伙计。这是最伟大的表演，它是珍娜·费舍作为帕姆·比斯利所做的精彩、持续表演的一部分。在我看来，这是电视史上捕捉到的最伟大的表演之一。是啊，它确实是。它确实是电视史上捕捉到的最伟大的表演之一。我为他写了那段话，我觉得他表达得非常完美。谢谢你，布伦特。不，不。
Listen, in your defense, it is a fantastic performance. And that was just a heartfelt message from Brent about how moved he was. And really, everyone is, by Jim and Pam, they break our hearts all the time because that is what a sort of star-crossed lover's courtship is. It's one moment you're available for that other person, either physically or emotionally, and the other person isn't. And then it flips and they break your heart over and over until they hopefully find each other. Well, here's the thing. You know, I did not make up any of that performance. That was all written for me by the great Brent Forrester. But truly, it's like those directions were in the script. I didn't invent those. All of those moments of
听着，为你辩护，这确实是一场精彩的表演。那只是布伦特发自内心的信息，关于他有多感动。真的，每个人都被吉姆和帕姆感动了，他们总是让我们心碎，因为这就是那种星际恋人般的求爱。一个时刻你对另一个人有空，无论是身体上还是情感上，而另一个人没有。然后它反转了，他们一次又一次地让你心碎，直到他们最终找到彼此。好吧，事情是这样的。你知道，我没有编造任何表演。那都是伟大的布伦特·福雷斯特为我写的。但真的，就像那些指示都在剧本里一样。我没有发明那些。所有那些
embarrassment, those were all described to me in the script and I just had to play them. So the script and I just had to play them. So, you know, it's that some of the beautiful detail that we would get in our scripts that I so appreciated as a performer, those quiet moments that they allowed to play out, those moments of silence, moments of realization. We always took our time with those and it and it allowed me to like really go for it. I loved it. Well, it's great and that scene broke my heart. There are a lot of moments in this episode where I was just as excited as Pam was that Jim was going to be back and then he's just not available to you. So it was really hard to watch.
尴尬的时刻，那些都在剧本里描述给我了，我只需要表演出来。所以剧本和我只需要表演出来。所以，你知道，这就是我们在剧本中得到的一些美丽的细节，作为表演者我非常感激，那些允许展开的安静时刻，那些沉默的时刻，领悟的时刻。我们总是花时间处理那些，它让我能够真正地投入进去。我喜欢它。好吧，它很棒，那个场景让我心碎。这一集里有很多时刻，我像帕姆一样兴奋，以为吉姆要回来了，然后他却对你没空。所以看的时候真的很艰难。
Yeah. It's like a brick wall. Like a brick wall. Like a brick wall. Well, luckily this episode does not end there. It does not end on Pam's heartbreak or this awkward moment. It ends with a fantastic scene between Andy and Dwight where they're arguing about their cars, their IQs. They have an amazing like coughing. They do they insult contest. You're an idiot. Like they do this weird. You're a big idiot.
是啊。就像一堵砖墙。就像一堵砖墙。就像一堵砖墙。好吧，幸运的是这一集没有在那里结束。它没有以帕姆的心碎或这个尴尬的时刻结束。它以安迪和德怀特之间精彩的场景结束，他们争论着他们的车，他们的智商。他们有很棒的咳嗽。他们进行侮辱比赛。你是个白痴。就像他们做这种奇怪的。你是个大白痴。
I have a fan catch in this final scene. Reese Parasol wrote in and said at 28 minutes 42 seconds, if you're watching the iTunes version. So Dwight and Andy are fighting over their car. Andy's like 1985 called once his Trans Am back and Dwight goes, huh, well, it's an 87, so there. But in the pilot, when Dwight is describing his car to Ryan the temp, he says it's a 1978 Trans Am. Oh. All right, so fantastic catch, Reese.
我在最后这个场景里有一个粉丝捕捉。里斯·帕拉索写道，在28分42秒，如果你看的是iTunes版本。所以德怀特和安迪在为他们的车争吵。安迪说1985年打电话来要回他的火鸟（Trans Am）。德怀特说，哼，好吧，那是87年的，所以呢。但在试播集中，当德怀特向临时工瑞安描述他的车时，他说那是1978年的火鸟。噢。好吧，所以精彩的捕捉，里斯。
And oh, hold up. Sam is saying he has a little info about this car. Sam? Yeah, I think I can solve this one, actually. I think from the pilot in the first couple of seasons, he has a 1978 Nissan 280Z. And I think you can see it in the grief counseling episode when Pam and Roy walk outside to talk about her new car.
噢，等等。萨姆说他有一点关于这辆车的信息。萨姆？是啊，我想我能解决这个问题，其实。我想从试播集和前几季来看，他有一辆1978年的日产280Z。我想你可以在《悲伤辅导》那一集中看到它，当帕姆和罗伊走到外面谈论她的新车时。
And then at some point he gets a 1987 Pontiac Trans Am. That's the maroon one you see most of the season. So it's just two different cars. And I know this because I grew up in the 80s in a car family and my uncle had the first car and my brother had the second car. And I've listened to much motley crew in both of them. Sam!
然后在某个时候他得到了一辆1987年的庞蒂亚克火鸟。那是你在大部分剧集中看到的栗色那辆。所以这只是两辆不同的车。我知道这一点是因为我在80年代的汽车家庭中长大，我叔叔有第一辆车，我哥哥有第二辆车。我在两辆车里都听过很多克鲁小丑乐队（Motley Crue）的歌。萨姆！
Whoa! Applause! Wow. Sam, add to your list muscle car knowledge. I love it. I have one thing I noticed about this scene, Angela. So we know that this elevator goes nowhere. Yeah.
哇！掌声！哇。萨姆，把肌肉车知识加到你的清单里。我喜欢。我有一件事关于这个场景注意到了，安吉拉。所以我们知道这个电梯哪儿也不去。是啊。
We know that when Andy and Dwight stepped into that elevator, it was just a room on a stage. And I clocked the moment when then the elevator doors open and they're suddenly quote unquote downstairs in the lobby, they had to film that at two different times in two different buildings. And you can see the moment that the camera cuts. And that's the moment it starts to move, it pans to the left, and then there's a cut.
我们知道当安迪和德怀特走进那个电梯时，那只是舞台上的一个房间。我注意到了电梯门打开，他们突然“下楼”到了大厅的那一刻，他们不得不在两个不同的时间、两个不同的建筑里拍摄。你可以看到摄像机剪辑的那一刻。那就是它开始移动的那一刻，它向左平移，然后有一个剪辑。
And that is when they were now relocated in the different stage for the exiting of the elevator. And so it's a fun little moment to watch, I think. You and Reese getting all the catches in that final scene. But it looks so seamless. It looks so seamless. It really seems like that elevator went from one floor to another.
那就是他们现在被重新安置在不同的舞台上以走出电梯的时候。所以我觉得这是一个很有趣的小时刻。你和里斯在最后那个场景里捕捉到了所有东西。但它看起来天衣无缝。它看起来天衣无缝。它看起来真的像那个电梯从一层楼到了另一层楼。
Well, I have one deleted scene I want to talk about before we close out the merger here. You know, Jenna, we've talked before that John and I rarely interacted as characters. Yeah. We rarely spoke to each other on camera. Well, in the deleted scenes, there's a scene where Jim goes to accounting.
好吧，在结束合并话题之前，我想谈谈一个删减场景。你知道，珍娜，我们之前谈过约翰和我作为角色很少互动。是啊。我们在镜头前很少说话。好吧，在删减场景里，有一个场景是吉姆去会计部。
Kevin says that he hid his M&Ms under his desk if he wants any, they're under his desk, but he didn't want the other people to have them. And then Jim looks at me and goes, hi, Angela. And I go, you need a haircut. And he goes- Hi, Angela. And I go, You need a haircut. And he goes, Wow. And he goes, Bye Angela. And he leaves the scene. And that's it. That's all the scene was. But then they left the camera rolling. And we improvised a beat. And it made it in the deleted scenes.
凯文说他把M&M巧克力豆藏在桌子底下，如果他想要的话，它们在桌子底下，但他不想让其他人吃。然后吉姆看着我说，嗨，安吉拉。我说，你需要理发。他说——嗨，安吉拉。我说，你需要理发。他说，哇。他说，再见，安吉拉。然后他离开了场景。就是这样。场景就是这样。但他们让摄像机继续录制。我们即兴发挥了一段。它被放进了删减场景里。
So after Jim leaves, Kevin goes, It is his first day back. And I say, his hair is flipping out on the sides. And Kevin goes, I like him. And I say, oh my Lord. Well, here's something though, and you said earlier in the clip that they ended up using of Kevin hiding his M&Ms, you're not even at your desk. I know, I would have been there because then Jim would have walked up. I don't know guys, I'm out.
所以吉姆走后，凯文说，这是他回来的第一天。我说，他的头发在两边乱翘。凯文说，我喜欢他。我说，噢，天哪。好吧，有一件事，你在之前播放的凯文藏M&M的剪辑里说，你甚至不在你的桌子旁。我知道，我本该在那里的，因为那样吉姆就会走过来。我不知道，伙计们，我出去了。
Interesting. I'm hanging out with the plant from the other day. I don't know where I am. Yeah, you're with Andy's coat and the plant. Yeah. Just the three of you. I'm in the box of lost things. Yes. Oh, all right guys, that was the merger. We want to thank Ken Whittingham and Brent Forster for sending in those awesome audio clips.
有趣。我和前几天的植物待在一起。我不知道我在哪儿。是啊，你和安迪的外套还有植物在一起。是啊。你们三个。我在失物招领箱里。是的。噢，好吧，伙计们，这就是合并。我们要感谢肯·惠廷汉姆和布伦特·福雷斯特发来那些精彩的音频剪辑。
Ken is a prolific director. He is directing just about every TV show out there. The Upshaws, American Housewife. Yes, also Bless This Mess, but I will not hold that against you, Ken, because, you know, Bless This Mess is the show that replaced my canceled show, Splitting Up Together. But it's okay. It's okay. I'm not bitter. I'll let you guys get into that when he's on Phyllis's Wedding. Okay. And Ken left us a little clip saying goodbye and where you can find him on the socials. Thank you so much, Angela and Jenna for having me do this. Of all the
肯是一位多产的导演。他几乎在执导现在所有的电视节目。《阿普肖一家》、《美国家庭主妇》。是的，还有《祝福这团糟》（Bless This Mess），但我不会因为这个而记恨你，肯，因为，你知道，《祝福这团糟》是取代我被取消的节目《分分合合》（Splitting Up Together）的节目。但没关系。没关系。我不苦。等他上《菲利斯的婚礼》那一集时，我会让你们聊这个。好的。肯给我们留下了一段小剪辑，说再见，并告诉大家在哪里可以在社交媒体上找到他。非常感谢安吉拉和珍娜邀请我做这个。在我做过的所有
television I've done, some of my best memories are being with you guys on the office. So let's do some more of these podcasts and talk about Phyllis' wedding and some other episodes I've done. So Ken Whittingham, at Ken Whittingham on Twitter and Kenny Witt on Instagram. And also thank you to Brent Forrester.
电视节目中，我最美好的回忆之一就是和你们在《办公室》里在一起。所以让我们多做一些这样的播客，谈谈《菲利斯的婚礼》和其他我做过的剧集。所以肯·惠廷汉姆，推特上是@KenWhittingham，Instagram上是@KennyWitt。还要感谢布伦特·福雷斯特。
We're going to have him back again in the future. Guys, Brent Forrester is the head writer for Space Force Season 1. And he also online has Brent Forrester's Comedy Knowledge School. It's awesome. It's a six-week workshop on half-hour comedy writing.
未来我们会让他再回来。伙计们，布伦特·福雷斯特是《太空部队》第一季的首席编剧。他在网上还有“布伦特·福雷斯特喜剧知识学校”。太棒了。这是一个为期六周的半小时喜剧写作研讨会。
You can Google it. You can also find it over on YouTube at Reach Forrester. I love that. I absolutely love that. Well, everybody, that was the merger. Thank you so much for listening in and we can't wait to see you next week. See you next week.
你可以谷歌一下。你也可以在YouTube上找到它，搜索“Reach Forrester”。我喜欢那个。我绝对喜欢那个。好吧，各位，这就是合并。非常感谢你们的收听，我们迫不及待地想在下周见到你们。下周见。
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwulf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jorkins and our audio engineer and associate producer is Molly Nugent.
感谢收听《办公室女士》的“第二杯”。本集最初是与Earwulf合作制作的。《办公室女士》由Odyssey呈现，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·乔金斯，我们的音频工程师兼助理制片人是莫莉·纽金特。
Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. you you you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Odyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨进行混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。你你你 本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。